you guess who's on motherfuckas it's me
me me me me stupid-ass in five four
three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast today I have my
man's my guy who's the man
we got Giovanni hey all practice my name
what the [ __ ] I believe is Giovanni it's
G you know what you finally on the
[ __ ] genius brain podcast your way in
here did I tricked him I was like I
can't believe it
we've been friends for how long like
like you're my you're my son's
unofficial grand
what is it god Godfather Godfather
you've married us
like I have a house a room for you in my
house and then I like like that's that's
everything I've given you
like I give you for so [ __ ] long I'm
sick I swear to god dude so if you guys
don't know Gio was actually I actually
met her through a text conversation
first because I meant Barton Joe at the
San Diego Asian Film Festival yeah when
I first met Barton Joe I was dressed
very casually I like this big ol shirt
with like a panda on it it was like my
merchant what I'm wearing is casual but
your dress ik traps
I was the truth I was wearing flip-flops
and socks trash she's red and black
Jordan shirts a jacket and a t-shirt and
I came on and then Bart and Joe were
like what the [ __ ] how come he can dress
like that and I can't yeah because at
that time I just I don't know why I did
this but I made it a point just address
as shitty as possible yeah so when I
when I first did YouTube a lot of people
don't know if you look back at my old
videos every shirt that I wore was a
free shirt yeah it was either given to
me or it was a shirt that I picked up at
a car wash or it was some kind of funny
little car that I was doing but it was
it was funny to be that nobody really
kind of picked up on it but I just I
just hated dressing up I hated trying to
be something that I wasn't yeah I mean
you're a big hater but everybody would
dress up super nice and it wasn't who I
was and then Plus as a comic you don't
have to look nice to be funny so it
doesn't matter right but you were
telling them that they had a dress well
because it looked like garbage
they look like trash they look like ex
[ __ ] convict cholos Joe was bald at
the time yep Bart always had like his
spy I mean he's had the same hairstyle
but like they just look so intimidating
and like they didn't look like comedians
they just look like they were gonna rob
you
so yeah I was just like at least dressed
up a little bit and they didn't even
dress up that much it was just jeans and
a [ __ ] Dickies jacket I mean Vicki's
shirt that had just kidding films in Old
English like it was like mechanics dude
right it wasn't like a [ __ ]
improvement and they made it sound like
I made them go to like [ __ ] Nordstrom
or something and I get some stylists to
come in like I'm like bro just change
your shirt like we just we just didn't
like dressing up man and it was so funny
too because I didn't do it for the
longest time yeah and I just I think it
was just so uncomfortable plus I was a
bigger guy so I was sweating all the
time yeah so I just didn't want to sweat
so I was like [ __ ] it like I'm just
gonna wear t-shirt shorts yes no I just
wanted people to our I just wanted girls
to want to [ __ ] them I could get a
fanbase I don't know I just do old
school tactics and I'm like I just want
girls to [ __ ] you want to [ __ ] you and
then guys to want to be like well how
did you even get into this this is
actually something I don't know how did
you even get into being involved as like
managing them because you used to manage
them kind of very loosely like no one
can really manage them because they're
[Laughter]
but it was one of those where the crew
was really small at this point it was
barge obviously myself and I think at
this time it was just Casey so that's
right case that's when Casey was fat
with long hair and and that weird little
mustache he's a little greasy yeah yeah
he was pretty gross did a great job yeah
and then so we were all wearing so many
different hats and I I always had this
[ __ ] where I had to like prove myself
you know what I mean like I had some
[ __ ] to prove all the time so if someone
was like um like like try to get him
like yeah I could do that [ __ ] I could
get you there I could say I was always
like trying to get them into like shows
or different seating or like like you
have to be at this event I'm gonna get
you I don't know I was yeah so I had
this like attitude about myself that I'm
like uh like a flirty dude I guess so I
had I had big
energy or just dick energy maybe not big
so then I was like okay well because at
this point they had taken a hiatus for
like a year or two or something like
that and they were kind of becoming like
old news cuz it was like YouTube was
popping off yeah yeah yeah at this point
so when I came into the picture it was
like okay well let's revamp everything
so then that's when I was like where do
you need to be who do you need to be who
do you need to know how are we collab
so then um yeah that was pretty much
what I was doing like just linking them
up with everyone oh so that's why you
are reaching out to do these like
everyone collab yeah like I was there
like any event that they were at they
didn't really know the people so I'm
like okay so I was walking towards you
this is her name this is what they do
they were like okay cool thanks oh
really it was like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah cuz they were just like we were
writing not we I don't write any skits
but they were writing so many skits and
we were shooting so much that like we
were uploading a brand new skit like
every week yeah yeah once once or twice
a week sometimes I couldn't really like
I was like them to where I just didn't
want to reach out to people yeah only
because for me I didn't want somebody to
say that my success was because of
somebody else's hard work dang [ __ ]
Korean proud it was because that's why I
didn't want to collab I didn't collab
with you guys for the longest time at
first yes I actually I had a goal I was
like well I'll collab with these guys
cuz I like them a lot but I need to get
at least half a mil subscribers for
remember that yeah so until I get that
point then people could say it's
collaborative work yeah JK films gave
David so a hand yeah so then when things
started to even out I was a cool let's
talk about that David why why do you
feel like you're not enough bro no it's
not that I'm wasn't enough I knew I was
enough that was the problem I just don't
want somebody else to think that my hard
work is because of somebody else why why
do you care about so much about what
people think about you bro it's not that
it's not that all right it certainly can
cry all right no no no it was it was it
was a really good good moment too
because I always wanted to work with
them you know when I first met them at
San Diego because I liked them a lot
they are the only person I connected
with at that event did you know about
them before I didn't until somebody
mentioned that they were the Korean
History Channel guys uh I was like holy
[ __ ] prior to Bart and Joe doing that
video nobody knew how to imitate
Korean person yeah they coined that [ __ ]
nobody else did I knew them because my
cousin brought a video and brought heat
showed up on YouTube of this Korean
History Channel thing we're bringing a
video makes sense back in the day on
Thanksgiving anyway did you see this
video I was in tears laughs no fight and
so when I was there I connected I was
like yo you're the [ __ ] Korean
History Channel yeah dude yeah one of
the till this day it is still one of the
funniest [ __ ] videos on YouTube to me
I don't even remember it anymore but I
get the gist of it but I remember they
were not they were concealing their
identity yeah their ethnicity I should
say because they were like really about
this like Asian American movement and
like having all Asians like support each
other cuz at that time I guess now it's
different but at that time everything
was so segregated segregated like
Koreans only supported Koreans Chinese
were just doing their thing like no one
was really unified so when they were
doing that Joe was like damn I could
never reveal my ethnicity cuz of like
he's Japanese and there's that whole
Korean and Japanese thing he was like
afraid not afraid that's not the right
term but he was just like [ __ ] I don't
want people to like give me [ __ ] you
know when I look back on it it was I
think it was a mentality that they had
because they grew up in LA because it's
not like the no Sacramento it's not like
that in other parts of California in LA
it's like that a lot though
yeah so I think even when the fan base
was like why would you hide it it
doesn't make sense it's because la is
very segregated yeah people talk about
diversity a lot in this city and
diversity here is is a very it's a
skewed definition because there's
Koreatown where the cake Korean people
kick it there's [ __ ] East LA where
the Mexican people kick it and there's
like comedy we get everywhere bro East
LA is all there also in [ __ ] like
k-town as well
yeah thanks ago so it's it was very
segregated over here so I could see why
they would think that because especially
because at that time that they grew up
in and when I'm like three years younger
than them so their time to even though
was three years there was a lot of like
gang [ __ ] yeah it was like Korean gangs
here there was like watching hop sing
foo sing all these like Chinese
different gangs too so all things yeah
so it was all I think for them for them
like the races were kind of
compartmentalized but I think at that
time on YouTube people were just happy
to see Asian people on the screen while
they [ __ ] up I'll let them know
so go keep telling them about how how we
we met and then our relationship blossom
to something so beautiful and so
unbreakable that could almost cry just
thinking about it shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] sack of [ __ ] actually the funny
thing is so when I first met her she had
I thought she was a dude because of the
way that she would text yeah you got it
I hate when you [ __ ] [ __ ] bring up
the story like that you know you have to
say the first time I met Gio was through
text and then I thought she was a guy
cuz then what happens is you leave it
open for the dist
and it hurts my heart a little bit cuz
you go the first time I met her I
thought she was a dude and then they go
PI she does look like a man and I'm I'm
hurt well the dawn kind of scared me so
you [ __ ] better say it differently it
was text and I thought she was a dude
yeah and then when I met her her
mustache scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] but the
way that she would text was so [ __ ]
masculine like it sounded like a good I
know what that sounds like no because
like I mean I'm just cooking I want
business that's it
yeah but even for business it was like
some [ __ ] like what's up my guy it was
it was very dude like you know so I
assumed that Gio was for Giovanni and so
I was like why Italian plumber ass or
[ __ ] manager this is [ __ ] know what
they say about assuming what you make an
ass out of you oh that's [ __ ] cute
that I actually never heard that thank
you but I saw when I in my mind I
pictured this like hairy Italian [ __ ]
with like like the silk shirt that's
austere and so when you came up was like
who the [ __ ] is like what's up I'm Gio
I'm like I broke it the [ __ ] out here
where's this guy you know yeah yeah I
was kind of shocked that this was Gio is
like this tall Amazonian woman it's
beautiful woman okay let's not get ahead
of ourselves this angel from the heaven
you know yeah that was the first thing
he told me to you're like what the [ __ ]
I thought you were a dude yeah I'm like
well I didn't like you because you were
like so I texted you back or we were in
the middle of texting and I was trying
to book you for a skit and then you were
like oh I don't know my schedule just
hit on my manager and I'm
[ __ ] you just made one video that went
[ __ ] by a roll and all of a sudden to
my manager I was like I don't like this
fool okay let me just defend myself real
quick because I didn't know how
entertainment worked right yeah I was a
stand-up comic I was just trying to get
into clubs and get into a slot where I
could do past a five minute [ __ ] set
yes all I ever wanted to do when I
started having a manager and he said
just bring everything to me I just
listen to whatever he said make sense
but like I like [ __ ] going in on you
I just didn't know what was going on so
when somebody asked me to collab I was
like okay let me just toss it over to
him because I was just busy hitting a
comedy clubs my thing was I was just
told you just be talent let me handle
everything yeah that's how it should be
so I just chucked it over to him but
when you might in retrospect when I look
back at it it's very douchey to do that
[ __ ] yeah cuz I'm like we've already
talked he's stupid a-holes yeah cuz if
it was like if it was like Barton Joe
cuz you're technically his manager their
managers like the same thing yeah so
manager talks to manager I was like yeah
well I'll just talk to Barton Joe and
see what's up I mean like well you since
your manager mr. guy wants you talked to
my [ __ ] man alright bro you didn't
make it fun anymore okay it was fun
forth and now that I think about it
logically you're correct it was pretty
[ __ ] up on my part but I'm not gonna
apologize all right exactly there's a
couple of things to that when I first
met it was like they didn't they
wouldn't
explicitly say that they were together
yeah but you know but you could tell
when there's couple energy you know I
mean it was like oh these two are
together
the people the person I didn't know that
because I was dick no it wasn't that you
were very distant but you guys always
had you guys a roast and I was like oh
these two were together for sure even
from the first time I met them and even
Joe they wouldn't tell me what Joe was
smells like this [ __ ]
japanese-held yeah cuz he caught him
smelling underwear he was always in the
corner yeah when I first met Joe it was
him peeping through blinds like this get
all these gadgets no you just look at
like ancient Japanese schools Joe's face
is right there yeah so when people
couldn't figure out his ethnicity I was
shocked
he's clearly Japanese yeah look at his
[ __ ] face yeah but everybody thought
he was there's not a single Vietnamese
person on earth that looks like Joe yeah
I would agree the first time I met him
um
like I knew exactly what he was yeah if
you just look in your history books and
they look up anything Japan you'll see
Joe's face drawn all over them yes Bart
was hard Bart
100% thought he was Korean yeah he has
that because of his nose his nose and
his face like his struct like he has a
very [ __ ] fat Korean head like I do
to me I don't want to say that I don't
know why but yeah you're the creepy
[ __ ] fat heads so I thought he didn't
have to go like this with your hands
like you have the fat head just point I
know I was doing this because Bart's
head's more square uh true to you know
mine's more like round this is square so
he has the big Korean head he has like
he knows all this Korean [ __ ] he would
talk about like his like tongue sayings
and stuff I'm like with you he was like
throwing the scent off dish and so when
I I didn't know that he was Chinese at
all because he just knew too much Korean
[ __ ] yes because he hung out with a
bunch of Korean people I would have
never [ __ ] known yeah and he has the
anger like a Korean person which you
know he's actually really nice the only
time I actually saw Bart angry was when
somebody was on your car it was when you
guys first opened up bar bell and there
was this guy that was writing a note on
the phone like this and he was writing a
note or something on your car and then
Bart asked him really nicely like hey
can you can you not write on my
girlfriend's car right and the guy just
went and he just kept writing on it and
then Bart walked up there he goes if you
don't [ __ ] move i'ma [ __ ] you up
he said that oh my god and I ran into
barbel and I opened up the place I got
scared
dude you saw what I used to look like
before I could get nobody's back I was
scared cuz I've never seen him angry
before although he's gonna kill him yeah
what is that I just opened up the blind
I'm like getting cupid's so scared
that's the first time I've ever actually
seen Bart mad yeah I've never seen him
mad since ever in my life but that was
one time I saw a glimpse of it and I
actually got like sweats
yeah he's scary when he's mad oh he's
gonna kill this guy I get him at all the
time let me know I'll record it for you
yeah that's different type of metas he
can't strike you he could strike the
[ __ ] out of that guy though yeah Bart
was telling me that he needs that
because he's like very energetic he has
to work out yes or he gets like
irritated if he does over the Christmas
break like he really wanted to spend
time like have family
time because we just don't see him that
much anymore he leaves like at 5:00 or
6:00 in the morning oh [ __ ] yeah and
then he comes home like at 7:00 and then
it's like tyka hour and then tyke goes
to bed and then he's already exhausted
so then during that break he wanted to
just hang out like wake up and we're all
in our PJs and you know when you just
lounge around and like you're just all
nasty all day so he wanted to be like
that and I think on the second or third
day he was just experiencing a lot of
anxiety and he just felt like like very
like panicky and he was just thinking
the worst case scenarios about things
and he was just in his head a lot I'm
like what the hell's going on he'll work
out dude yeah so then we went out and I
think we went like for bike ride or
something happened where he like got
some endorphins mm-hmm and then he was
like damn I think I really need to work
out all the time that's that's how I
Muriel is so if Muriel doesn't work out
she turns to this thing I call a [ __ ]
she turned into a [ __ ] big [ __ ]
and she knows it too so we figure a
[ __ ] - oh absolutely nerve okay no damn
it I was retiring up my f I don't call
her [ __ ] but she know that she turns
into this huge [ __ ] yeah that she's
agitated she feels like her skin's
crawling and so when she was feeling
really out of shape and it's cuz she got
sick and she couldn't work out she was
so [ __ ] mean and I was like yo man
let's go get into a gym you were like I
was like and I said I said [ __ ] no so
we found out that it's because she has
to work out so she went out and she did
like a cardio kickboxing class she came
back and she was just leveled out I was
like oh you need to work out work out
doing yeah she gets very antsy you have
to realize when she lived in Taiwan she
would bike everywhere she was biking
like 30 miles a day and that's just how
active she is yeah rock climbs she does
everything that's true yeah she's she
doesn't seem like someone that bounces
off the wall but does she have ADHD at
all
maybe man but she doesn't let it get to
her because she's always active she's
always moving she's not moving she's
agitated but ever since I lost the
weight if I don't move I get agitated
now oh that's why you always see me
moving around jabbing and [ __ ] like I
think I've always had like ADHD
I was so fat it's just weighing me down
[ __ ] crazy man so Muriel noticed that
a lot she goes like you cannot stop
fidgeting now like you just you went
from not moving at all to moving all the
time you can't stay rock to human yeah
she said that she was mentioning today
too because we just had breakfast and
she was like I remember that you know
when I haven't seen you in a while
because we live separately you would
come over I would come over and then you
would just look at me like let's just
lay down for a second even though I just
came into the room because you were so
out of shape yeah she goes now you're
just like let's go here let's go there
let's walk here and then now you're
upset at me for being lazy yeah that's
tight yeah I'm so [ __ ] proud of you
you piece of [ __ ] a man is it's hard
work like working out dude I'll tell you
this dude I don't think I could ever go
back to being like super overweight
again you just don't feel good you've
always been overweight I've been
overweight I fluctuated a lot so I was
always like a chubby or fat guy in high
school and then there was a stint in
college where I got really really fat
[ __ ] they're gonna say skinny but no no
no it's well that happened after so
there was a stint in college from like
the 1st to 2nd year well first year and
maybe a few months in I got really fat I
was with a girl got really depressed she
dumped me damn it I was about to see you
were getting laid oh yes I was you call
it you find a girl with some low
self-esteem they do just about anything
so I'm telling you he's not wrong yeah I
said this on a podcast before men any
guys out there that say they can't get a
girl it's just because you don't swing
enough you just gotta get rejected a lot
and somebody will say well we know some
people that this swing is and it get
rejected so it's not for everybody
exactly yeah so I got really really big
and then you know it was that kind of
went really extreme with working out so
I started doing kickboxing and I started
doing was same thing now [ __ ] is
smarter and I started doing a lot of
CrossFit and then I dropped like 50
pounds in like five months ah you know
when you're younger to you have a lot
more time I was only going to school and
I was failing at school so I didn't
really go to school yeah good for you
yeah I would take this a pre-workout
called jack'd and that thing was in
saying is that the one that had like the
[ __ ] illegal stuff like okay nishan
yes I am mmm so I was taking that so I
would do like CrossFit workouts now I
would play basketball for three
and I just wouldn't go to class and then
I would do kickboxing on the weekends
and I dropped all that weight felt
really good sort of but then I kept
hurting myself I fractured my ankle
playing basketball my my left one and
that's why you have this little
ossification yeah so I had this little
little bone that form there then I
gained all my weight back and then I
just stayed fat and then it was I was in
the comedy so you know I went back to
comment so I didn't really need to be
fit and I didn't carry much you still
[ __ ] the ladies I've got some ladies
dude it's hard though and it's weird to
when I think I feel like a lot of in
cells like they don't understand they go
well how come he got girls and I
couldn't guys do and it was like was
because you just didn't try hard enough
and maybe you just were socially awkward
yeah you know so you just you know you
you could I think girls are way less
shallow than men absolutely a hundred
percent there's like studies that that
have been like multiple studies that
girls like five top three things do not
include the way that a guy looks yeah
for a guy the first thing is how a girl
looks yeah first exactly and it's very
interesting how that works out too
because yeah I mean rejection was not
good it didn't feel that great but when
I saw other guys swing constantly to I
was like oh I'm just gonna swing and see
what happens right and eventually
somebody will say I'm not saying that
these women were [ __ ] fine as hell
you know what I mean but they're all
listening like mad you know you are that
you were [ __ ] around with me come on
now we were at the same level you're not
an ugly dude thank you but at that time
really gross so I I can't believe I just
said that I had to pause myself you know
what it is she I'm just trying to butter
you up bro I'm gonna [ __ ] happen
we're gonna make [ __ ] David cry okay
we're gonna do this I cried too much
lately dude no I'm gonna do it I'm all
dried out but going back to you it's so
funny because like with her I think she
always had like this facade of like Oh
miss J I miss macho girl I don't care
about winning rings I don't care about
nothing yeah I just rolling my eyes like
did you are soft as [ __ ] why didn't you
tell me stupid [ __ ]
I think everybody told you though
everybody did but you didn't realize it
you're so know I didn't know I was
completely oblivious I thought that's
who I was
yeah because when you said you did a
ring everybody well whatever dude but
you're not your [ __ ] about that [ __ ] I
didn't realize
additional I was you are traditional
yeah you know and it's and it's
interesting too because I think I
realize how nice of a person she was was
when I had this this old Camry and I was
driving on the freeway and this dude had
a bunch of bricks to another
construction ship on it
brick flew off took out one of my tires
and I kind of like put on Instagram
story at the time and then the first
person that calls me is her she calls me
and she asked me if I'm okay if I need
any help I was like that's how sweet you
are [ __ ] did happen she was so sweet
before anybody else contacted me she
contacted me first now are the mics
breaking no I was shocked all the holy
[ __ ] like this girl's really really
sweet and I started to see like little
small things outside she [ __ ] cared
about me you would have to like really
squint and sit still to see like the
glimpses of like the chick geo trying to
come out huh no but you were very very
feminine though was I yeah and it always
felt like you know when I don't I think
it what it felt like was you would have
this tendency to try to always prove
somebody wrong even though nobody was
saying that you couldn't do something I
know I don't know I mean I know where
that comes from now but I hate that you
know what I mean I was like yeah buddy
called you weak nobody called you
anything but it's like I could do this
[ __ ] I could do this [ __ ] [ __ ] nobody
said you couldn't oh I know I don't know
why I was trying always I like I like
recently this year was like you know
doing a lot of like self-discovery and
[ __ ] and I realized that I'm like
contour at least I was I was constantly
just trying to prove myself worth to
people like when I respect someone
because I don't respect a lot of people
but when I finally respect someone I
want them to feel like I'm on their
level like that's how [ __ ] pathetic
that like I was why why why I wanted to
be on their level yeah why cuz I just
felt like they were they possessed
things that I didn't have yet at the
moment or there were things that I'm
like that I was just like wow I admire
that about you so much I want to possess
that too so like that's where the
respect came and I just felt like well
I'm not on your level just have but I'm
gonna get there and I think I think that
mentality that though it's wrong has
like really helped me to be where I'm at
now because I was always like I'm
beneath you but I want to be on your
level but you're so but you're you in
the
last like two three years you bid a lot
more emotional like emotionally
available
yes you're a lot I mean it's all like
the sweetness that I really enjoyed
about you and I always thought that you
were a lot more so you gonna cry
no I always thought that you are a lot
more sweet to me but also to I'm a very
like I'm a very churchy open loving guy
yeah you are so you're very sweet to me
but now you kind of have that same
sweetness with other people too now like
you're a lot more open to like our
friend group you know yeah I feel like
with me and you it's always been like
that yeah you created a safe space for
me yeah so we're always like we always
can hug each other we can always have
fun talk openly and stuff like that yeah
but I could see you doing that with a
lot more other people now I'm like oh
she's a lot more open now yeah I don't
know I don't know what happened I mean I
know what happened there were a lot of
things that definitely challenged me in
my life and it was just one of those
where like I wanted to be a good person
for tyka because I'm just like [ __ ] man
like I just felt like like I had deep
relationships with people or so I
thought but I felt like the way I would
see you have a deep relation you put
someone versus my relationship with
someone else um I just felt like damn
that's not that deep
like in my heart I wanted it to be even
deeper but I just didn't know how to
take it to the next level and I always
felt like [ __ ] what's wrong with me that
I can't connect with people like what
what is it that I'm lacking what is it
that I'm missing I I feel like it can go
like my relationship with XYZ person can
be dip deeper but I just don't know how
to get it there and I just always
thought something was wrong with me and
then so are you can can you like connect
with people better now then oh
absolutely absolutely because before it
just felt like I had so much anxiety and
I and I had like I guess low self-esteem
where I just felt like I didn't I didn't
belong at the table that I was at in my
group of people and then I just felt
like I didn't know enough like I just
I'm like okay well I don't know what
you're talking about but let me just try
to like pretend or like I'm just gonna
live I never know what I'm talking about
yeah yeah I love that [ __ ] though
because like the most the most popular
comment I used to get on juniors is like
Davis oh such a hypocrite he doesn't
know he's talking about I'm like I never
said I did
never said I did I just like talking
yeah the way that you could take
whatever you want it's not my
responsibility to fact-check myself you
fact-checked my [ __ ] loser yeah I mean
well I heard you say was fat check yeah
fat check me in fact check me homie I
know I don't give a [ __ ] but that's so
interesting that cuz I think a lot of
people wouldn't understand why you would
have low self-esteem because on the
outside everybody looks at you oh my god
this makes my self-esteem for people
that I care about though oh it's not
like strangers no I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
about strangers cuz I'm like who the
[ __ ] are you like like are you even at
my level not to say that I'm like that
sounds so [ __ ] cocky but I'd just be
like we're not even at the same table
Dawg like yeah because I don't [ __ ]
know sit over there no we're not we're
not we're not yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
about other people yeah but if I gave a
[ __ ] about you it's cuz I respected you
and I love you and I'm like look I want
like I need to earn this love from you
and I was you know the high anxiety in
my mind was always going like like why
did you say it like that damn they're
gonna think you're a [ __ ] like like I
don't know any of that stuff dude when I
meet somebody I just follow my gut I'm
like is this person [ __ ] weird
or they not yeah I mean and I like weird
people I like weird but fun you know if
you're just [ __ ] weird I hate that
[ __ ] am i weird you know weird dude
you're really weird what time you're
[ __ ] odd dude I like all I think all
my really really close friends that I
love that considered family they're very
[ __ ] odd yeah you know but the the
quality that they all had the most is
loyalty so like if that's like the main
thing that matters the most so yeah cuz
you seem like people that I hang out
with they all have that one similar
qualities like I trust them I tossed my
house keys key to you I'm okay you
wouldn't rob me and the same thing if
you gave me your house keys
I want to rob you yeah yeah I feel that
so but they're all different all
different walks of Lies some of them
grew up in the nicest neighborhood some
of them the shitty neighborhoods but
that one thing is is kind of binds them
all is loyalty and also they they're not
socially awkward yeah so that's what I
really prefer yeah yeah I mean you can't
really connect with someone that's
socially awkward it's hard man I try
dude yeah I try sometimes cuz like I I
understand what they go through because
I was also very socially awkward and I
still have my socially awkward moments
when I go to these Hollywood stuff and I
don't want to connect with people yeah
I just became okay with it it's like oh
I'm socially awkward because I could
give a [ __ ] less about you that's why
that jersey hustles really awkward I am
because I'm like you sound perfectly
fine to me okay and then other people
are probably going like goddamn that was
weird and I'm like I get it one thing I
know about you though it's like it I
don't think you like silences me like in
like when you when you when you meet
somebody or there's a good you I think
you always like to try to make them feel
comfortable so you always try to talk to
them as much as you can and there's no
silences because I know I have a RBF and
I don't want people to feel
uncomfortable or oh is that with that
and it depends like if this person you
brought this person out then that's your
side right to you yeah but like if um if
this person just kind of randomly showed
up I don't give a [ __ ] mmm like I won't
even look in their direction because I'm
really I'm really comfortable with like
you Bart
and Joe now so like for me like I always
tell like I think even with mariachi go
sometimes you just don't talk to me is
like because I'm like that with people I
care about a lot I feel that to the core
yeah like I just I could just be around
you yeah and I'm happy absolutely I
don't I don't need to have a in-depth
conversation with it'll happen a lot if
we haven't seen each other in a while
but literally if you just sat there all
day didn't do anything I'm pretty happy
I'm like saying good because it just
feels comfortably being around family
yeah it does and like we just figured
like we know each other for so long we
like why do we have a talk right exactly
it's just like cool you just come in
like even at JK news we would be out
there you know in my Honda Element
and she's like I'm gonna come here chill
me all right go ahead yeah and it's so
comfortable yeah and we just chill and
then things are really cool I think
that's when life's like friendships
really start to form or it starts to
become family like because when you grow
up in a family you don't need to talk to
your family member every day they're
just there yes like cool brother or
sisters here yeah and then you just hang
out and this happens you're like my type
of people though like um you're just so
upfront like I don't have to guess
around you like I know if you're upset I
know if you're happy um and and I just
kind of know how to navigate around that
yeah it's just so straightforward and
that's just what I need it's just with
other people where I'm like oh well I
don't know what to do and maybe that's
when you hear the no pauses because I
like I'm like look am I like being an
[ __ ] right now like should like
that's when the anxiety [ __ ] kicks in
and I have to be like okay wait I got a
talk because that's what normal people
do
we talk this podcast is brought to you
by purple my friends purple mattress
makes me feel good good for my back and
good for my sleep before I had a purple
I was a walking zombie that's an
original song they probably won't use it
but on this podcast they have to use it
well my purple mattress my friends is
one of my favorite things on earth
because it gives me the best sleep I
used to have a terrible patch before
because everybody told me that a spring
mattress with like a top or something
was the best thing to do or it was the
best thing for your back and they lied
because I use a purple mattress and I've
had the best sleep I've ever had in my
life 100 I trust free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you could return
your mattress for a full refund backed
by a 10-year warranty free shipping and
return you're going to love purple and
right now my listeners will get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts they're offering sightline
just to explain to 84-88
the only way to get this free pillow is
a text brain to eight four eight eight
that's be are a I n to eight four eight
eight eight well one of the things I'm
trying to fix two is like when I have
this weird gut thing that I don't like
something like somebody it's highly
apparent and I'm trying to learn how to
like not show it as much so like that's
what Nick says he goes I could tell you
don't like that guy what do you mean he
goes hi Hills I trust me I could tell
like you're all happy and then when this
person talks you just doing that I'm
like [ __ ] man saying dude I don't know
um [ __ ] I don't know maybe operate with
[ __ ] love you piece of [ __ ] maybe I
did it's hard but it's like sometimes
people say stuff and I'm just like God
guy like you and I don't like when I
went to a wedding with a Mariel recently
and they're I can't believe that
everybody at that wedding wedding I
[ __ ] hated everyone at that wedding
yeah grandma the grandma too she could
get it too but we were at the wedding
and you know the person that I liked was
the person that was getting married and
the husband but there was just people
there that the conversations were so
[ __ ] annoying and how they were and
there was this guy there too who kind of
probably reminds me of my younger self
but he's like 38 right everything that
he was say
was a [ __ ] joke like I just met him
and he was just joke joke joke joke joke
couldn't get a word in edgewise and I'm
like bro nobody's laughing at your [ __ ]
like your first couple jokes got a
couple of smirks end up on top drop it
so he just kept doing it over and over
in her eye jokes and [ __ ] bad jokes
interrupting our conversations and I'm
like yo bro shut the [ __ ] up he's like
I'll be right back I'm gonna go get some
drinks anyone I'm gonna make like a
banana and Sicily [ __ ] like that
oh [ __ ] it's like come on guy a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bag shut the [ __ ] up and I wanted
to say that [ __ ] but mirrors like you
don't like him and I was like can you
tell ya like I'm this is like I'm very
good at being social when I have to be
in a weddings is my [ __ ] because I'll
turn it on this one I was I can't do it
and I just opened up my phone I don't
even play games I start playing games on
my phone oh [ __ ] I feel that dude I feel
that to the [ __ ] core you and I don't
like a lot of the same people we bond
cuz I'm like that person right there I
don't [ __ ] like them you're like say
yeah I don't like them and I could it's
just Steve out of me dude I'm like oh I
[ __ ] I don't know I don't like that
either about myself cuz I'm like well I
shouldn't say I mean I'm I'm kind of
okay with it but I want to change it I
hope be more loving 2020 is [ __ ] love
year for me I'm trying to I will always
follow my gut feeling and you know it's
it's been wrong quite a few times but
I'm okay with being wrong
you know cuz what am I really losing is
what I feel but then when that person
when just because everybody else gives
them a chance it doesn't mean I will cuz
I'm gonna follow my gut now it has been
wrong a few times but I say for me 90%
of the times it's been pretty right so
I'm just gonna go with that probability
yeah it is not because that person is a
evil person sometimes it's just you and
I gel we don't vibe dude yeah and that's
okay yeah yeah but then sometimes some
people just they're like oh why are you
being so I'm not being mean to you it's
just everything you say makes me want to
shoot myself in the face so it's better
that I don't talk to you and I avoid
that conversation because then it'll be
confrontational because you and I just
aren't we're not the same people we're
not cut from the same cloth
and I'm cool with that yeah I just have
to be cool with it too then we can you
know Sam I get along you can say what's
up all that other stuff you know give
each other gaps have like conversation
but when you try it is like no let's get
some lunch that's crap nah bro Wayne
that lunch I mean I'm not gonna sit here
and talk to you Sam
with you I like sandwiches yeah yeah
myself I can't do with that yeah yeah it
was crazy cuz like I thought that that
was the norm right and I thought like
okay there's just some people you can't
gel with and of course you have your
close circle of people or whatever but I
was like always wondering like is it
really like that like like like if I
don't if I have this gut feeling or I
don't vibe with them that I'm just gonna
have like my [ __ ] you face on and I'm
like annoyed or if they say some [ __ ]
I'm just like God shut up but then I
went to the seminar this Tony I [ __ ]
sound like everything you [ __ ] heard
me on I did I bring it up and I swear I
mean it's not a call girl you didn't
take the [ __ ] kool-aid deal has
joined the cult and I have been trying
to get her out of it for I'm kidding
she's not no it's not even a joke it's
not even a cult I didn't close Tony
Robbins by the way I actually know quite
a few people that has gone to Tony
Robbins seminar that they all loved it
tight so so in this so I went to it and
there's 5,000 people and like when
people operate with like not trying to
prove [ __ ] not trying to like be like
we're like what's your status in life
and how can we like collaborate or gain
from each other like when people just
operate vulnerably from their heart it
was like [ __ ] dope I was with 5,000
people and I felt like all of those
people were my best friends yeah that's
that's the hard part about being an
entertainment interfere that it's that's
what this business is it's am I gonna
develop this relationship with somebody
because I can take away something from
my career yeah and that's why it was so
hard for me to be in acting because I've
never operated that way my channel has
never operated that way I've only done
stuff that I've liked if something was
poppin and popular I couldn't do it
because I didn't like it mind you if I
liked it I would do it right you know
like the Kangnam style style although I
got a pair yeah you have to either I did
that but then yes and it was I actually
do really look like him but there was
and then you know when there was like
the time when people were doing Asian
people said black people say yeah I
didn't find any of that funny I didn't
do it right you know it would have been
great for my channel but that's not how
I operate so I didn't do these that's
why you're my [ __ ] people man like
you're not fake I love that I love it
but it's not very good for business tell
you that no
though think about it like like even
with like we we're fortunate enough to
be in spaces that we can talk to people
that are like highly successful in their
industry like I'm talking about like
famous people and for them like I
respect them because they're just like
we just want to hang out not because of
what you can do for me but because
you're cool and if something flourishes
from it cool it might be today might be
tomorrow might be ten years from now but
let's just see if we just vibe yeah and
that's the type of [ __ ] that I like to
do like if I vibe with it I'm gonna roll
with it if I'm not if I can't vibe like
you're gonna like my face if I don't
like something or you then I can't hide
it yeah like it's just if there's no
longevity with that
yeah and I'm always like we know we
talked about this to where I always I
think towards the the latter end of 2019
my biggest thing that I started to
realize that I didn't something I didn't
like in people were people who weren't
who aren't very grateful so like I
cannot stand that it bothers me a lot
and you know I've had this conversation
with Joe too where I started to realize
the people that I'm not close to are the
ones that complain about stuff that
other people wish that they had yeah so
that's the hard part for me because you
know uh you know you grew up in East LA
I grew up in like South Sacramento my
best friend and I we connect so much
till this day because he he and I were
always grateful for our [ __ ] yeah you
know I mean like I I think when I
started making a lot of money I kind of
forgot a little bit about that stuff and
so I got things because I wanted to have
it just to say [ __ ] you to somebody
right right I mean we grew up so [ __ ]
poor - yeah I think finally it's our
chance to get like the [ __ ] thing
that we always wanted mm-hmm I know and
it felt good at the moment but all those
stuff started to become very fleeting
yeah so that's why I didn't focus on my
health I was like what I was trying to
make myself feel better for better was
by buying things right I bought new
shoes I got better clothes I got the
nice car I got all this other stuff and
I just sat around and the moment that I
had the car it felt great for the first
like month and then it disappeared and I
was like what next let me go buy
something else
true bro that's so true you try to fill
this this hole with stuff you try to
fill this hole with air yeah that's all
that it is and so I started to realize
oh good rich [ __ ] you're like I got
this
new car and like you know after I make
so much more money than me you shut the
[ __ ] up I took a two-year break I was
broke I'm not complaining but after I
bought like my TV nice my third Alvey
purse I was like ah I you know it's fine
to cuz even then when I was buying thing
and I was still very frugal but it was
like I lose stuff that I would never
ever think about buying you know any
mean like I don't even like cars why the
[ __ ] why no I bought that as I like tech
yeah so you know I still love that car
but at the time I just thought to myself
like something really small it was like
I bought a car that cost me after
insurance and everything else I decked
out this this Model S and it was like
you know 1500 a month I could have got I
could have kept my same Jeep no actually
gave that to my parents but I could have
got another car what a good piece of
[ __ ] you are whatever I could have had
like a so I could have gotten like a
decent car that I would have enjoyed and
that rest of that money let's say it was
like a thousand dollars I could have
gained it my parents like why didn't I
think like that dude that's what I'm
saying we grew up poor like like for me
it was dope to like experience it get it
out of my system once it's out of my
system I'm like cool bigger than that I
don't gotta go back yeah people like us
we move forward yeah is what I've
noticed like like if I want to do
something I do it and I'm like okay is
that something I'm gonna keep around is
this something I'm gonna keep doing yes
no I assess it and then I'm like okay
cool got it out of my system moving on
that's white yeah and then you know I'm
glad that we did go through that stuff
yeah cuz if I didn't I'm probably
wondering why I guess it was younger
yeah and you don't have cute like you
don't have why am I on your [ __ ] side
right now he's getting on my side put
some gas in this [ __ ] room what do
you think that nice oh yes I did dude I
heard something goes like a pink mist
going on right now
what the [ __ ] I mean [ __ ] you yours but
that's what it is like we we spent money
on stuff that we didn't like and that's
why I started spending money more on
traveling because when I started to
realize that the things that I enjoyed
the most that I got to look back on no
matter how many times I went was
traveling I look back at these memories
and it makes me feel good I don't look
back at the test and be like god I
remember when I had that Model S and it
was decked out I remember when I had all
these like Jays and [ __ ] it didn't make
me feel good yeah so I sold a majority
of my shoes I got rid of the Model S and
then I had the Honda which I have to get
a new
[ __ ] it pisses me off it [ __ ] sorry
but quick story yeah I see why it's
breaking down now because he's always
complaining about his [ __ ] car that
keeps breaking down this [ __ ]
not only showed up late to his own party
three minutes late is it this award late
stole in that sentence oh you didn't be
a great mom your kid's gonna hate their
guts go ahead where I'm already
preparing for the [ __ ] backup for
three and a half um so he was already
not only was he late but he walks to me
we're about to walk up here and I hear
his [ __ ] car engine on I'm like
because I'm so excited to see her I was
so happy and look how beautiful she is
today
her beauty took my breath away and then
I lost air and I passed out and I forgot
to turn off my car you think that's what
it is
okay but yeah that car sucked in
breaking down now but even then the
thought about me buying a new car
bothers me because I'll have to spend
money on this [ __ ] yeah become very very
frugal lately I am like I don't care
about like a lot of material things now
and I really understand now why people
when they make a certain amount of money
they just don't care and I actually
learned a lot from when I go to Hawaii
like a lot of these dudes biggest
working like the part-time jobs whatever
they're so happy they're happy they have
families their kids are fed everything's
cool and I'm like no how come I can't
have what they have in terms of
happiness when I have more than I need
right and it made me feel terrible I'm
like I have more than I need like my
parents do they used to work man [ __ ] my
precious to work 80 hours a week
damn yeah so they used to open the store
around like 8 to 7 a.m. depending and
then they we would close the store at
8:00 p.m. Monday through Saturday then
my dad would go to seminary school
online and then I would work at the
church my mom and dad would look at the
church on Sundays that's what I'm saying
my mom used to cook food for the week so
and on Saturdays to 400 Akio the Korean
school hang that Akio yangon Akio we
would at night I said I used to complain
cuz I had to make sandwiches and you
know do all the drink stuff for the
lunch for the hunger Tokyo kids and that
I was a part of as well so I would do
that for my mom and then my mom on
Sundays would cook food for the whole
church of like 300 people but you go
back to work on Monday and so this is
where everything that I came from and
then I'm a complaining about the small
little things that I don't have doesn't
really make sense I think that's why
once again just to wrap it back I don't
like people who aren't great
for what they have if you have if you
have a lot of the things already that
most that you kind of take granted for
just like I know this sounds dumb and
when you get older if there's a lot of
younger people listening to this food
shelter family friends those things are
fulfilled life is pretty [ __ ] good it
is it's pretty dope yeah that's why I
like um when I have kids I'm a put him
in a church and I'm a send in my mission
trips because that gave me a lot of
clarity to mission trips help gives you
a lot of clarity because you really get
to see how other people live and it's
their [ __ ] daily life why don't you
just live in the hood have two houses
one in the hood where they get like shot
up all a shot at I'm going I'm gonna
trim and show my kids till they're 18
yeah and then we're just gonna have a
really rough life and then all some up
kick this cardboard down I like look
daddy has money [ __ ] I know her family
not my family member but I know of
someone that has it
I don't think Park is a [ __ ] he so is
Bart's cousin his uh his uncle is pretty
well-off in Taiwan and he's a debt has
his own practice as a dentist and he has
like multiple houses out there and his
kids never knew about any of that wealth
and it wasn't until they were like 18
that they were like what the [ __ ] we
suffered so [ __ ] much and we had all
like we have nice cars we have a [ __ ]
dope ass like why did you do this to us
like we went to school with other rich
kids but we were the poorest ones there
like they would wear hand-me-down
clothes and just I I'm like that's
[ __ ] up I want to do that okay I
really do I'm so scared that might when
I have kids like they're gonna grow to
be spoiled shame dude I'm scared right
now I'm like [ __ ] am i doing too much
for taiko and I try to like shut that
voice in my head and going like no no no
it's good this is all training this is
all true
I'm scared too because like I even I see
smart like Tyga's not even my kid but
you [ __ ] up and I just think I can't
stop smiling and I'm like I don't want
to give him stuff and I look at bar tab
bar sits like I know man I was like yeah
like I like my kid you know I mean so
yeah no no no no you're not
it's different when it's your kid okay I
was like oh suffering no other people's
kids I'm like oh that's so cute he just
threw that at your head that's [ __ ]
good then Tiger doesn't like you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] he doing he's so smart
he's really smart she's a little too
smart he talks so much right now he'll
be like mama what do you do
that's for the other day we're at the
house this will kept on taking all the
toys putting into the bucket and I'm
like watching the fight what's up and he
dumps the clothes toys on him to be like
80 times and I didn't stop laughing cuz
I'll funny it is to me yeah but he just
wants to grab your attention and he's so
[ __ ] cute I love that kid dude yeah
he's the best
he's the best yeah but I'm with you a
hundred percent when someone is
ungrateful I think um uh I don't know if
I recognize it off the bat but there's
like this feeling that I get where I'm
like damn some think about you is wrong
wears off or I don't I don't vibe with
that but now that you keep that you
pointed out that ungratefulness I think
that really irks me too yeah because
it's um it's there's there's just a lot
of things that's encapsulated about not
being grateful that kind of like broods
certain personality traits that I don't
like right yeah the people who are so
very ungrateful are also whiners and
complainers there are also people who
don't take on personal responsibility
it's just a litany of things that I
don't like about a person that starts
with not having gratitude yeah and
that's a very important part and it's it
also helps with just kind of like being
happy - it does looking for positive
things in your life yes if you ever say
to me like anybody comes up to me while
you have it good but you didn't grow up
with me when I was a kid you didn't you
didn't grow up with me you don't know
what it's like how can you have it good
with the face like that that's what I'm
saying dude because you know it's hard
being so pretty oh this [ __ ] right here
let me tell you this quick story right
you know jk jk has his name where when
we have problems we all like to come
together and then talk about our issues
and so we're all having a heartfelt
moment people are crying people are
opening up they're talking you're laying
it all really they are talking about
like growing up with like crackhead moms
they're talking about you know getting
their ass beat not feeling any
self-worth and this [ __ ] dead silent
the room she goes no no I got something
to say she goes yeah you know my whole
life you guys don't know what it's like
being beautiful
you can hear the eyes roll of the room I
felt all the drafts from all the [ __ ]
eye rolling like I just I was like oh
thank you the time wasn't right now I
was like family right now [ __ ] room
[ __ ] I could not stop laughing listen I
understand her point was about but she's
gonna tell her point which makes
complete [ __ ] sense was it when its
encapsulated right but the moment was so
awful I thought it was a safe space I
thought it was a judgment-free zone I
thought we were family
god bless Nicky for Jeff she I think
she's so [ __ ] intelligent that she
read the room and was like oh this [ __ ]
done [ __ ] up that day and she was like
yeah I can relate to that Gio and I'm
like Jesus Christ thank you so much
Nicky [ __ ] I love you forever
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny baby no
if I want to explain it I think I just
want to leave people thinking I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] no you should explain to
what she means by it because I get it
cuz I wouldn't understand cuz I was
never treated this way but please
continue cut down okay so so the reason
why like so we were really trying to
uncover like our triggers and stuff and
and and in order for me to relate or
give advice or my two cents to someone I
have to be able to empathize and really
put myself in that situation so that I
can give the best advice possible or
just suggestions or whatever so then I
forgot what we were talking about but I
was just like [ __ ] yeah like why do I
have a [ __ ] resting [ __ ] face like
why am I always so standoffish like Bart
caused me a porcupine like like I'm cute
like you know behind closed doors but
with the public I'm just the spiky
person like get away from me [ __ ] you
you know and I'm like why am I like that
I'm like oh [ __ ]
okay I think it stems from like the
neighborhood I grew up in like if you
didn't grow up in East LA I'll let you
know like and if you're a girl it
doesn't matter how you're dressed I
could be have this this jacket zipped up
from like the bottom of my feet all the
way to my like chin and I'm still gonna
get catcalled like I'm so she's not a
dream by the way because I actually do
remember seeing this happened to her for
the first time we actually were going to
go eat at parks barbecue is is really
good
Pino barbecue spot in your k-town and
she should know she was dressed in
regular clothes
this dude rides up in his car H right at
her and Bart what the [ __ ] was that yeah
yeah she's like some real [ __ ] yeah and
I'm not this I'm not saying Mexicans or
Latinos or whatever they're all this way
but there is a part of the culture
though there's a there's a big-ass
[ __ ] handful of people that or men
that do that to women so growing up with
that I was always like [ __ ] you like I'm
not your piece of meat I'm not here for
your [ __ ] entertainment so I started
putting on this persona of like like I'm
kind of manly like why would you want to
[ __ ] something that's manly like are you
gay bro you wanna move dude you know so
I would I would try to like put myself
like in show myself in that light and
then like when it came with friends to
like this isn't high school or junior
high like I would find out that when I
thought we were friends they wanted more
and I'm like oh man like you were such a
good friend [ __ ]
so then I always thought it was my fault
cuz I'm like [ __ ] okay well maybe I'm
like giving off the wrong signals here
like maybe I'm flirting or no guys just
think that they take kindnesses flirting
all the time then that's why I wouldn't
want to be kind of be like the hot dog
right hit him like I would act like
another guy just like all she [ __ ]
touched me dude like she's like one of
us yeah or like yeah like I've had
girlfriends in the past like in high
school or the like why are you flirting
with my man and I'm like what the [ __ ]
like he looks at me I don't know like so
there were so many things that like over
the years on Mike man this [ __ ] sucks
like I have to it sounds so stupid when
I say it out loud no I I do understand
what you're going through even though I
don't know what it's like because nobody
has ever ever done any of those things
to me ever in my life yeah what the [ __ ]
you flirting with my woman dude I'm like
but I do understand what that feels like
because I think for what you're saying
it's just kind of like you don't know
who to be because everything that you do
you're walking on [ __ ] eggshells yeah
I'm trying to be super macho but then I
don't feel like myself so it [ __ ]
sucks
yeah I let my guard down and then
they're like why you [ __ ] hitting on
my man it's like well what the [ __ ] do
you want from me now yeah you know yeah
that's literally the story of my life
I'm like damn I'm trying to like be
other things for other people to make
them feel comfortable you have to hang
out with other hot [ __ ] dude
and then it's all gravy I did I didn't
it was gravy and then other people have
to be already in relationships you got
to find the right pieces yeah and I did
like the whole Jacob like all the girls
are [ __ ] smoke shows you know so it
has no qualms there I mean is that's all
just like people dealing with their own
personal like insecurities and stuff too
and it's so funny how we it's how this
wraps up to another podcast we're
talking about how guys just sometimes
they when they're young - they're so
[ __ ] horny they only they take a
woman's kindness as them oh this could
possibly be a relationship yeah I was
like well maybe you're a nice guy and
she's a nice girl yeah and you know when
a girl is really like flirting there's
bigger signs yeah it's different it's a
[ __ ] different vibe yeah what I mean
and so I think a lot of these guys who
like to develop relationships by
sneaking in yeah [ __ ] weasels I don't
like that yeah they always do it that
way and that's what's kind of work for
them when they find a girl who's a
little down and out from a relationship
or something else and they go hey I can
be your shoulder to cry on those guys if
you're one of those guys [ __ ] you I hate
you I hate guys that are like that I
hate it I hate guys like that too I'm
like you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
yeah cause they're all so afraid of
rejection and yeah what happens is they
go they either say oh I got friendzone
or they say like nice guys finish last
yeah suck a dick and I hate that phrase
the most and probably heard the [ __ ] in
three podcast recently just because I
hate it so my god they were your guests
no it's just I've been seeing it pop up
a lot recently it's been it's been on my
nerves you know cuz they're trying to
relate to somebody in some type of way
they're like yeah I'm just a nice that's
why I'm always singles like no you're
seeing because you're a loser right
right because you also don't there's
someone for everyone but like like the
[ __ ] there's people that will find
their perfect partner to [ __ ] on their
chest
think about that you don't to me like
that's a [ __ ] wild [ __ ] but they
they're in love and they make it work
I'm like you're there's you need some
[ __ ] self-reflecting bro - no Tony
Robbins I was I was in that [ __ ] that
the big mood podcast now and you know
just Gina talking about her weird
preferences I was like yeah what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you man
she was like nope there's no such thing
as too much choking I'm like yeah
there's not what are you saying right
now I was like - you blacked out Joker
yuck my YUM yeah you can't you're saying
weird [ __ ] I'm like all right there is
somebody for everybody out there some
guy that's gonna nut on his own face and
eat it then I guess that's you like you
[ __ ] weirdo what are you saying right
now so eh yeah so I don't want to hear
that [ __ ] that good guys food is less
it's like now just be honest like that's
the first step let's be honest yeah be
real honest too like I just is so
interesting to like see that's what she
meant by the pretty people problem you
know it's just hard being so beautiful
it's all okay yeah we're wrapping it up
yeah I got it going are you gonna make
fun of me I was waiting no I got you dog
I understand dude it's very very
different yeah you know what it's like
being ugly dude it's hard no I have no
idea yeah it's a lot harder okay it's
way more [ __ ] different but you're
funny
and girls don't give a [ __ ] about what
you look they do care not that much not
I've dated this is gonna sound so [ __ ]
up I've dated very unattractive people I
think most of my guys have been not like
the tens and not on purpose they just
have the best [ __ ] personalities I
know but the looks do matter to a
certain extent because and I like guys
have to get that - it's you there's - it
does matter you know I mean it plays a
role but it's not the only thing oh for
sure it's not the only thing I think it
matters more for four men than it does
for women yeah you guys are visually
stimulated yeah I mean that's that's not
a bad thing I think that's just for my
you know my anecdotal observations and
stuff like that but David it's biology
okay it's biology I don't [ __ ] know
it is what it is right but for sure like
guys you still have to like clean
yourself up
smells please like come on yes you have
to smell good brush your teeth wear
deodorant a little cologne goes a long
way that's every girl but what we were
just talking about that yeah really nice
yeah it's like you'll remember smells
like you'll remember not what they say
obviously you can remember how they made
you feel Maya Angelou whatever but
you're gonna remember how they smell
like even Mariel to like I don't I don't
really smell as nice as I used to
because Mariel only wants you to smell
nice for her now so she doesn't like it
when I do all that other stuff she go
well how come when we went our last time
you didn't that's why don't do anymore
that's funny she's so funny
yeah she's very she's never like that
about anything but for some reason with
that scent that's how important scent is
to women she's like well if you're not
going out with me why do you need to
smell that nice I was like but I always
smell nice like cuz I'm the fat guy what
if I smell that's what was though yeah
it was all such a fat dude I didn't want
to be fat smelly guy no you smell great
yeah so I was like you um you can be fat
David but you'll never refat smelly
David yeah so I always made sure I
smelled the way that I smelled yeah you
know those always these two colognes I
always mix together and this is the
Orang that I always use so I always make
sure I smelled good and so and after
Merida was like I kind of she likes it
to be special for her I just I gotta
[ __ ] it then I'll just be regular
smelling David now and I like that I
didn't realize how important have you
your own thing was like I I didn't
understand that concept because when
Bart and I were together everything was
online like our whole CUNY Talk was
online and like a part of me never
wanted that to be online but I didn't
know why I didn't even know that I
didn't want that online oh I didn't
understand that I was just like
something about it just makes me feel
weird that you know it and I just
thought that I was embarrassed by it
that's what I thought it was I thought I
was embarrassed by people knowing that
we're like cute behind the scenes oh you
didn't want the no none of that I wanted
it all to be private I'm like a very
very private person for sure um and I
wanted it to be my thing and then once
it was revealed on my [ __ ] it's not
special anymore so I get where she's
coming from like in a relationship you
have to have your special bubble thing
mmm so I get it like before I would have
judged Mariel and what I would have been
like damn she's [ __ ] controlling yeah
but now I'm like no that's like your
like personal love thing and that's
[ __ ] beautiful so do you guys have
something now that's not the the QT talk
that you do that's just for you guys
no it's just the horny sexy talk oh we
didn't have that before but now we have
what are you sexy talk we had that
before
um bro we were a [ __ ] mess man so we
were like soul mates madly in love that
moved quickly into business partners
mm-hmm that lowered like employee boss
relationship because I'm working with JK
that then quickly
he escalated to business partners where
were now equals and all we ever did was
work work work so the relationship was
just on the back burner and sex just
kind of became one of those things where
it's like [ __ ] okay well I can't shake
this horniness wanna [ __ ] okay let's do
it and it was just like like this just
get it get it over with so there was no
real connection because we weren't we
weren't acting like a couple because we
didn't have anything personal that was
ours it was like like let like this is
just what he liked yeah and they like
let's just get it done
so yeah we didn't have any of that
really we [ __ ] we've come a long way
man now we're just we're the best we've
ever been so now we have that but you
guys have been together for such a long
time though yeah you guys also did ask
the field so at the time when you guys
were doing ask the field wasn't like
that as well
yeah I mean because we had like decent
sex it wasn't like horrible it was
pretty bad but but but as the fuel was
about arasta fields was about like just
your experiences your sexual experiences
so it wasn't necessarily just with him
like I've had other partners not just an
accumulation of stories oh and then also
just like my own fantasies were shared
too oh I never seen an episode of ask
the fields yes please don't push it a
little too much for me like it's it was
like I it's it's entertaining for you
guys but I've known these people for so
[ __ ] long
if I have to listen to like 30 minutes
of like come talk for my people have
known for that long it's yeah it might
be funny here and there but it's a
little it's still a little weird for me
you know especially if you're not in the
conversation exactly if I'm just
voyeuristic Lee watching it's weird yeah
but if I was in the room it's funny yeah
but now I'm like I don't need a list I
can't even watch any of my friends [ __ ]
I can't do it because I thought their
being fake that's not it at all it's
just that they have like their vision
and their branding and and they stick to
that and for me I'm like you shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here like I
know the truth not that they're lying
yeah I want to emphasize that like
they're still being themselves but it's
just a different level of like details
or intimacy that we have yeah it's very
important though just to have something
special for that's why for Muriel like
for the longest time I didn't talk about
her right
she's never really that much on my
channel you know I put her I just
recently started putting in more stories
like here and there and then she has her
own like Instagram page but other than
that and then she's been on the podcast
a few times other than that a lot of our
personal stuff like you guys will never
know that [ __ ] yeah I like this sounds
is that possessive Muriel is mine
that's my yeah and say that's my wife we
have personal special things that I
don't think it's pretty for anybody else
to know yeah I didn't even want to put
up that originally I wasn't going to put
up the proposal video and I put up three
months later and I just sat on it and I
was like you know this is actually kind
of sweet and I think like I want people
to see what a real relationship looks
like like this is how awkward you are
yeah very awkward I was so nervous
I know you know I was mad that's the
only thing I watched that was yours yeah
and you know I was like this is kind of
sweet and the marital is okay with it I
was like cool well let's put it up like
I think it'll be nice but at first I was
very apprehensive about putting it up
because I think having special things
between me and her makes things more
exciting it does you know it does
because like again like there's so much
of you that you give to your friends
that you give to your audience that you
give to your parents like in it and it's
nice to have like that special
connection or memories or just talks
with each other like Barden I didn't
have that like we would go on trips and
it was everyone we'd go on a date and
it's with everyone and it was very true
and it's cool and I'd like that because
I love you guys but at the same time I'm
like wait where do I stand then in this
relationship like I knew what was a
significant other but I'm like what sets
me apart other than us seeing each other
naked yeah like when you mention that
too like when we were all hanging out
and stuff right and you know at times it
was like what was like yo let's hang out
right or it's like you know I'm gonna go
eat it was either you were always there
and I was like oh like I guess he always
has his girl with him all the time or
that he was like me and Joey you want to
come let's go he's like I just need you
I'm like yeah I'm gonna eat by yourself
or it was always like that
it was always you him and somebody else
or it was the other way around yeah so I
was like oh that's kind of it I guess
they're just you know they've been
together for a while now so they don't
maybe don't need that time but that was
something that you needed
and I thought it was high school that I
wanted that I thought I was being very
like immature like like I need to be
around him like all the time and I'm
like that's weird why do I need to do
that yeah and I didn't realize like
there's a balance bro like you should
connect with your with your partner
one-on-one and and there's just a
different energy it's a different vibe
you have different conversations mm-hmm
yeah I didn't know I just thought I was
being selfish and he's like not very
well at least back then he wasn't very
emotionally intelligent so for him it
was like well we all love each other
don't we let's all hang out
you know I Bart - is very interesting
because he's a very emotional person but
he he doesn't sometimes he doesn't know
how to analyze other people's emotions
yeah I mean his own yeah so he doesn't
know what happens so when he really says
like I need you to explain this to me he
needs you to explain it to him because
he's not saying it to be like [ __ ] you I
don't know what's going on he generally
doesn't [ __ ] really yeah and I feel bad
because it's frustrating I'm like what
do you mean a hug works like this this
is what a hug supposed to do is I don't
I mean I'm exaggerating here of course
but like to that degree where I'm like
[ __ ] this is so [ __ ] frustrating even
so she got so frustrated she would call
me or text me like can you explain this
to Barney and then one time - we were
training I had to take Bart aside and
like a bro this and this is why what you
said was not right you need to go home
and apologize and he's like so he's not
trying to be an ass ever no ever
he always and I've always told her - I
was like the best thing about Bart is
that he always has the best intentions
always and he's always he always without
fails tries yes and so if anything else
my biggest like indicator of somebody
who is really good to be in a
relationship with is even though they're
not perfect they're always trying to
make sure that doing right and that's
who Bart is yeah max he always tries
yeah yes yes quality I love that I think
anyone's best like I don't care what you
did I don't care the decisions that you
make as long as you learn from it and
you change them I'm assuming that
they're bad right and if I see you
trying to change that like you feel like
[ __ ] I hate that about myself and you
try to change it oh my god I'm yours
forever
yeah and it's not going to be like a 180
turn right when it happens when you
figure out what the prob
is it's gonna be small baby steps
there's like habits like me putting the
toilet seat down like I told Mara she
used to hate it and we had a big
conversation not too long ago where I
was telling her I was like hey you can't
keep yelling me yelling at me about this
toilet seat down she put it this she put
it up when she's done no she does
nothing thing exactly but you know what
I told her was that I grew up in a
household where it was all boys and
there was one lady so I've been doing
this for 20 plus years you can't expect
me to change overnight but I need you to
acknowledge that I'm trying my best so
if I had a toilet seat up three times
out the week well guess what that means
like the others whatever 40 times it was
down so my ratio is pretty good so you
can't take it as he's saying [ __ ] you to
me he doesn't want to do this yeah it's
I'm trying but I mean what again just
give me that grace yeah and I told her
to like I've given you that grace
multiple times I remember back in the
day when used to [ __ ] knee me in the
nuts and you thought it was my god I
remember that yes are you so mad and she
goes like why I'm just play fighting you
are hitting my baby maker yeah and I
told it you don't know what it feels
like it's I'm if you hit me in the nuts
and I collapse to the floor yeah that's
huge pretty bad I was like yeah if you
like nut check me it's like a slight
sting but you're sticking your knee full
force into my nut sack there in your
neck yeah and so I'm just on the floor
and she's like you go you let your other
like girlfriends hit you they don't
strike me in my nut sack like that yeah
do you not understand when he I think
you were in cheer or wrestling uh in an
Instagram picture like post and then she
has to type it and she's so [ __ ] cute
she touched it how come he never lets me
do that to him I know I'm like what are
you what are you saying she's like well
he's doing all this stuff feels like
it's different dude and I also want you
to be my fiancee milady you know what I
mean yeah so this is the same thing if
you don't want me to treat another girl
like the way I treat you
it's very different right we're special
like I like I find you attractive I find
you sexy like this is what I like yeah
so don't expect me to have the friend
pickle fighting ballsack punches like I
have with them with you yeah that's here
I was like you wouldn't want that yeah
you want me to find you attracted you
want me not to want those things from
you yeah you know but I think sometimes
she kind of sees that as like
I'm having a certain type of fun with
other people then without her I'll say
but the type of phone we have I'm not
giving that to other women so you got to
understand say it like that uh yeah you
know the time I'm gonna oh you know I'm
saying you know I'm saying Oh play
Connect four
you know saying and when we play
Monopoly I hopefully monopoly with
nobody else all right we play Monopoly
that's good you know yeah so like it's
true too like if you probably told her
that way it's like oh yeah I can kind of
see that you know oh are you hinting
that I maybe if you told her that then
maybe she would kind of understand yeah
yeah you know I mean no she's different
now yes evolved so much she's the best I
mean now we just bicker that's the only
thing that I know I went I went hiking
with Nicole and oh my god all I heard
was and I'm like thank god it's mommy
that's how we bicker dude hey both of
you are wrong that was a beautiful thing
so they were talking about oh we all
about David wanting a car and she's like
but you said you hate that car and he
goes I never said I hate it and then he
kept going you said you hate it and then
they were both wrong and I was just like
there with Tyga and fawn just laughing
cuz I'm like y'all both dumb no she's
wrong she was wrong and I was right no
for the record she was wrong and I was
right cuz you're trying to play a memory
game and then like literally one thing
you said you didn't say you did say and
I was like that's [ __ ] well you guys
are all done you're done you don't even
know what's going on you're like dude
how about your picture but yeah we get
over things pretty fast when we first
bought our first two years though she
and I were at just locking horns all the
time well you fought hot we fought oh
it's bad no we fought so much like we
fought all the time locking horns with
two guys would have been knocking that's
like two dicks [ __ ] whichever but no
locking horns means fighting okay about
where we used to fight 24/7 all the
[ __ ] time like scream at each other I
remember I hated that [ __ ] dude yeah
how's that oh [ __ ] I might have to leave
this girl cuz she doesn't she brings the
worst qualities out of me but then we
just feel stupid that just meant that
you really cared about her cuz if you
didn't give a [ __ ] about her it wouldn't
even be a topic of conversation you'd be
like you're dumb next one oh and I found
that out with the
last girl that I was with and I really
didn't care about her which was true but
I didn't really recognize that because
she would just go do whatever I'm like
all right cool whatever I just move on
right and then she hated that she's like
oh how come he doesn't really care I
like I do care I'm just letting you live
yes you don't care that's good I didn't
care yeah I didn't really care whether
you got home or not I didn't care I just
assumed that you would always be okay
but what Muriel is different I'm like
I'm mad I'm mad at her because she's so
physically [ __ ] weak it bothers me
she's not though like she has a I mean I
guess you probably know but I feel like
if if you had to put us to fight each
other I'd feel like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to go a little bit harder on no you
would absolutely destroy her because her
upper body's very weak so I'm trying to
get her involved in jujitsu classes I
think it'll help with like self
confidence as well too so I just want
her to be able that's why she has pepper
spray [ __ ] on her no I ain't trying to
have her get raped yeah and I don't I
don't think so that was a type of [ __ ]
that would piss me off about Bart too
cuz he like this is the difference in
perspective that we had in our
relationship was that he thought I was
so capable not not that I'm not I'm
pretty [ __ ] capable but he saw me as
is huh as is very capable independent
queen as he put it so anytime a guy
would hit on me he wouldn't he would
never come in to be like are you okay is
he bothering you none of that he would
just stand off to the side and just
laugh mm-hmm
cuz he was like I know she's gonna
reject his ass it's gonna be so funny
but I would feel unsafe because I'm like
dude it's like I remember the most
recent one are back in the day he was
like 6 7 or something huge round and I'm
like holy [ __ ] I'm like babe are you
like gonna like rescue and he wouldn't
do anything I wouldn't have either that
guy six seven yeah and I'm like he's not
gonna slap you but you sure as [ __ ] slap
the [ __ ] out of me yeah but I mean but I
wanted to feel small and protected well
I was small and unprotected alright I
understand
there was a 67 hitting on Muriel I would
walked in and be like listen man you
like some water like I'm hot [ __ ] you
would not do that you would do a soap
car you wouldn't do that either but you
would make sure she's okay hmm I mean I
woulda just pretended to be the gay
friend then I was like girl you need to
stop just grab her away she's not
interested in you [ __ ] and I
just give him up you would not do that
have died not do that I I think she's
very capable um
guess it goes to show who I do care and
I don't care about because what that
last girl that I was with there was just
big old black dude that was hitting on
her she felt very uncommon and I
couldn't stop laughing so I walked away
and this was at the airport and I was
like hey are you acting are you okay
she's like where are you and I was like
tell her that you already have a
boyfriend and I sent her a picture of
Terry Crews naked show that - you suck
yeah it was really funny though I was no
girls hate that oh she did hate things
that girls that will end up intimate
relationship or will make a relationship
really bad it's what I learned one of
them is females need to feel seen and
you do a really good job at that so you
already are smashing it they're like if
we get like a haircut if our man and
this is specifically for intimate
relationships if a man's like wow you
did something different did you cut your
hair or is that a new shirt or damn I
like those shoes with kind of like
becoming a friend ish but like just it
shows us that you pay attention to us
yeah and that fresh goes a long way the
second one not in any particular order
but the second one is we have to feel
like you're trying to understand us
mm-hmm so whenever we're venting or and
you're good at this - that's how you're
like my girlfriend um yeah but yeah like
whenever we're venting it's because
we're venting and we just need to get it
out and blow off some steam not because
we're we're hopeless and we don't know
what to do it's just like just listen
and just ask questions don't try to
solve our problems the final one is
feeling unsafe like if we ever feel
unsafe then that will for sure what
about if the guy feels unsafe at the
same time then he's a [ __ ] who's gonna
comfort who huh I don't know who warms
the Sun David I don't know these answers
okay those are really important like
those things those are huge those are
huge in a relationship and then for men
they have three C's
the first one is men don't want to be
criticized by their women which is kind
of funny then that's very detrimental to
them right because a man wants to be
your superhero he wants he's doing
everything for you and I'm talking about
a mature man I agree with that right I'm
talking about a mature man not an
immature man that's like [ __ ]
immature so he doesn't want to be
criticized by his woman
and that's what we called nagging yeah
that's what I call nagging and that'll
end it like you oh you'll start seeing
her differently you're like [ __ ] I don't
want to [ __ ] you right now because
you're being a [ __ ] the second one
again in no particular order is like
shut like cutting off communication like
anytime like if something's wrong right
and then we're like no I don't want to
talk about it but you clearly know
something's wrong like that eats away at
you guys for sure I told her that many
times yes I don't do this I also hate
when she goes hey I have something
important to never mind and I go son of
a [ __ ] you're about to ruin my whole
[ __ ] day tell me what it is so it's
really not that important just [ __ ]
tell me it's not it's nothing it doesn't
matter just tell me what it is she goes
I was gonna fart I'm like why didn't you
just tell me yeah god damn Lee but more
so it happens when like you know there's
like some type of trouble or like we're
arguing or bickering or something
happens like we need to keep clear
communication with you yeah the final
one is controlled anytime a man feels
completely controlled that's when shit's
context let's [ __ ] anybody man no no I
mature man like a man likes to feel free
like capable like he's capable to roam
and yeah Muriel does a great job of that
- Latoya like even with Joe he kind of
noticed - he goes yeah if I hit you up
like you don't have to ask her for
Brandi's come out of hangout it's like
yeah cuz I don't have to ask her for
permission for a [ __ ] like that
you know but if I go travel out of town
and I don't tell her that's where I get
in trouble of course ya know now she's
like he's he alive yeah like if you're
around the corner let's go get dinner
I'll just tell her hey I'm goin with
dinner I'll be back easy-peasy yeah
don't control me full all right I'm a
[ __ ] Firefly don't [ __ ] shut up my
life yeah that's any man mm-hmm
look at you that from toilets as well we
had a relationship day and they were
talking about like any successful
relationship needs to be polarizing
mm-hmm so some men possess more feminine
energy or some men possess more energy
you know I mean like we know some men
that are a little bit softer not to say
that it's a bad trait like it doesn't
matter if they're gay or straight they
just have more feminine energy and
that's okay but what tends to happen and
if they have a successful relationship
usually the females a bit more masculine
and that's okay because now they have
that polarity and they like that about
each other
and when I heard that I was like oh my
god that's really what nother thing that
happened with Bart and I back in the Bay
where I became a man too
so of course he's not gonna we're not
gonna want to be intimate cuz now he's
like I don't want to [ __ ] this man he
didn't know that mm-hmm he was just like
she's just not being soft she's not
being cute so because I was not being
soft and the whole cuny talk started
happening because he was like well I
gotta make this [ __ ] stop somehow Odin
would and then we talked that way and
now I'm like he's bringing on the
feminine energy where I'm going I don't
want to [ __ ] this baby I wreck up we had
a conversation it was so funny but he
was like I was like yeah you guys were
kind of joking I figured it was like Jay
keynoter we were just hanging out
because like yeah like I tried to hit on
all the time but she's not in the but
how did you try to hit on it oh god yeah
I was like how he was like you know I
was like did you did you like because
you said that you grabbed their asset
but did you grab her ass like you're
trying to [ __ ] or did you go like hey
mama baby I was like which one was it
because those two are different things
do I'm like I ain't trying to [ __ ] a
baby that's weird yeah yeah I'm like I
want a man like I want a man in bed and
that's a huge huge thing and once I like
revealed that and I when I figured it
out on my own I'm like oh [ __ ] I didn't
realize I'm Ariel - she's not one of
those people who were just like openly
into me you could tell like she's not
big on hugs she doesn't she didn't
really grow up with a lot of that stuff
but I grew up on a lot of hugs Yeah
right
so I hug everybody guys girls whatever
animals dogs babies I'm that guy you
know and so from Mariel like she even
liked the stuff when I you know I flirt
with her she's in like it when I grab
her ass and I'm like in public or even
an o' in ho' I'm like I like grabbed an
ass like that's my [ __ ] yeah you know so
she just like she'll she'll be okay with
it sometimes and sometimes not and then
she it was funny cuz she was asking her
best friend she goes name is where he
grabs my butt she goes what I love that
she was who doesn't love that stuff yeah
and I was like yeah every girl that I've
been with they like when you grab their
ass yeah you know I mean so I've always
tried to just grab her ass but she's
like doing the dishes or something like
that just like stop and I'm like damn it
I just wish you would like that because
that's something I like you know I mean
I like getting physicals I'm not gonna
do it some other random girl yeah yeah I
was like I'm gonna do it with you so if
I can't do it - anybody want me to grab
my own ass like
yeah let me grab a butt woman yeah did
she figure out where that comes from
she just never grew up with physical
touch like that so it kind of makes her
feel uncomfortable so even in on the
regular intimate level of hugging
friends even her co-workers know like
they'll hug her but they know that all
about the finesse that a little bit who
I got to make her feel uncomfortable now
because even with her she was like even
you know cuz I always say I love you to
you all the time I give you a hug I give
you a kiss before I leave
yeah and for her she was like I was like
I didn't grow up with that I always see
it so weird it's like you always so
comfortable with geo you're so
comfortable with Bart you get Bart a lot
of hugs and I just don't do that with my
friends I was like yeah because we're
family like I have to hug them like yeah
if I don't I feel weird
does she yearn for it like when she sees
you do it she goes man I wish I we hug
each other a lot but not you not heard
of you or you to her but like just that
feeling of connection with people - she
yeah she does your inference she wishes
she could do that with other people
where you know if she sees you she comes
up and gives you a family gives Bart a
fat hug cuz you know she always sees me
do it and I was like but you see my mom
and dad I get my mom kisses till this
day yeah I mean yeah I'm like
30-something years old she's 70 years
old I still give her kisses yeah like
this is how I grew up and she's got it
practice yeah and it's like this is what
I do this is the way I show affection
like if I don't do this for somebody
that I truly love it almost feels weird
now you know what I mean yeah it's odd
for me yeah you know I mean so I don't
know yeah thank you but you guys have
polarity oh for sure yeah like even with
your bickering like like you can sense
if things are starting to get a little
bit serious and by serious I don't mean
like intense yeah like when like there's
a weird relationship communication that
happens I guess it's it you could tell
we're like playing and bickering and
play fighting and then it gotta know
when to back down yeah there's that
little there's a that tone or that last
final word is you're like oh [ __ ] it's
about to go into series town and then
you sense her back off and be like more
feminine and I can sense you back off
and I sent you your guys's like David's
a man here and and she's doing what I
love about it the most is that she
always gets [ __ ] done that I don't want
to do like for example like we're going
to be at Nami to get our visa done right
like I hate doing that little [ __ ]
small little [ __ ] I can do it but it
bothers me but she'll get it done
without having
me as I'm like oh yeah when you take
control you know or when our flight
[ __ ] up she gets all the fights fixed
I'm like that's [ __ ] tight yeah cuz I
would have done it but I would just be
cursing up a storm as I do it yeah no
you would trust us the [ __ ] out exactly
so she goes I'll just [ __ ] do it
yeah so that's that's where I kind of
realize like I really need her for these
type of things because I can't do it
myself or if I can but it's just a
bigger ordeal yeah so polarity yeah I
mean you kind of got it but not really
but yeah yeah no polarity all right yeah
yeah okay that's where the Sun aligns
with the moon absolutely yeah the ocean
and the ocean currents come in and then
she'll start to me
oh yeah once you're gonna have the best
sex life ever bro polarity yeah well
that was how long have we been doing
this really an hour and a half oh no I
was like barely getting warmed up man do
it I you want to keep going I'm down I'm
down too let's keep going yeah what are
you talking about we are talking about
polarity and relationships [ __ ] I
learned so much I learned so much and
then what was dope and it was really
reassuring cuz I was like at the so at
this point in that so it's a six day
seminar by this point I think it's like
day three or four and I'm completely
like torn to shreds like I'm completely
vulnerable if you met me at that time
you would be like Gio is the warmest
kindest most loving softest female I've
ever met like I didn't even recognize
myself I already felt that about you
though but to where you didn't have to
squint to see that you know what I mean
like it was it was like I would look at
myself like had like what is it called
like out-of-body experience and I'm like
who it is my code is [ __ ] am I gonna
like her like I was dancing and being
all cute and I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah
um so by this point I'm like completely
open and vulnerable and he was like one
of the exercises was like okay like sit
there and really try to imagine what
your perfect relationship will look like
like what's what's the intimacy gonna
look like what's an argument going to
look like what's like an accomplishment
together gonna look like and you're just
sitting there and you're trying to
imagine like your perfect relationship
you know and like he's like okay now for
the next 10 minutes I want you to write
and as you're writing you can hear him
say like what about when this happens
what's the sex gonna be like what's this
gonna be like you know so he's he's
feeding you more like ideas to
right off of and like the more I wrote
and then when I completed my [ __ ]
four pages of what my perfect
relationship looks like I was like
crying I started crying because I'm like
[ __ ] I [ __ ] have that yeah it was it
was so dope it was soda like I could cry
right now just thinking about it that's
crazy I would have never thought that
that's so interesting that what well
what I'm thinking about like what my
perfect relationship is and if I I don't
everything to write it out I just kind
of know that I enjoy what I have yeah so
it's like like there you know people
will have thoughts of like yeah I'm a
guy so if I see it if I see a bad [ __ ]
I always look kill my oh [ __ ] that goes
[ __ ] fine as [ __ ] that's what guys
usually do and then it goes and then but
that's just as always as far as it goes
it goes big but it'll never go into
what's it like being with this girl
yeah oh I wish I was with her I wish you
were with me every day yeah it's never
gone from that from here like it always
stops here because all this other stuff
is already fulfilled by this woman here
you know and so it's like what I see
here is just that girl's fine is what it
is and then you move on you know so I
think that's when I start to realize oh
I really really care about this girl
yeah where it has never ever moved past
that like even like sometimes like if
you're a horny guy like you see this is
like maybe I want to [ __ ] that girl but
no that's like the thought that pops in
your head and then it just goes to
alright whatever move on right it's very
fleeting it's yeah it doesn't really
mean anything you know I mean yeah
absolutely just like this animal
attraction to somebody and then it goes
I had the thought I'm done and then you
just move on but like never like in
acting and then moving past that and has
never gone there because all this other
extra stuff this woman has all that yeah
I mean even this part that that where I
find this girl attractive she also has
that too so it's just no it's just your
lower biology I guess yeah not like
you're a yeah
yeah and then kind of going based off of
what you're saying right now he says
that when a woman if or when a woman
cheats it's usually because she felt
unseen mm-hmm I agree yeah cuz guys like
like you guys are visual like you just
said it you know like this hot chick
walks by like you're gonna look and you
go damn I wonder what it's like the
[ __ ] anyways moving on yeah like it's
not like you're trying to carry out a
[ __ ] scheme yeah but it's just like
it's just your biology so
like us female knowing that and then
like feeling like we're unseen by our
significant other like he was like
that's that's the number one my [ __ ]
eye a hundred percent agree though like
I think like a majority the people that
I know that went through that whole
phase it was because that whole unseen
thing help out happen a lot where
everybody I mean this is kind of
rudimentary but it's like people on the
surface everything looked great and
things were being ignored constantly
yeah but then it was just like now that
person didn't feel great yeah I mean but
you guys never sat down talked about it
yeah he was a guy thought everything was
fine and dandy because there was a roof
over the head bills were being paid yeah
then this person wasn't being
acknowledged and then just started to
[ __ ] up and then usually for the guy is
just that [ __ ] just wanted to
[ __ ] different [ __ ] yeah like oh [ __ ]
this is so interesting yeah that's how
it is for the guys anyways they just
either got drunk or they just wanted to
[ __ ] somebody else and they just [ __ ]
somebody doesn't they [ __ ] up so you
know god yeah talk about the guy how
that happens because I figured like for
guys it's just cuz he's [ __ ] morning I
don't know or maybe because all those
things just didn't happen he probably
had before I'm just talking about my
experiences where the dudes like a
couple of friends who like cheated it
was because he got drunk and he just
[ __ ] somebody yeah or and it wasn't
because things were bad between them
they just this guy just [ __ ] horny
like he always wants to [ __ ] random
girls yeah and he was like that before
he got with this girl and then when he
got a little drunk all his inhibitions
went away oh well he just you know
[ __ ] his girl and then they had to go
through the whole experience Bart and I
are so good now I think if he were did
she like if you were to have sex with
someone I'm so secure with the type of
love that we have that I'd be like Dan
that's [ __ ] up I wish you would've
came to me but if it happened I think
I'd be like okay well that it happened
like just don't do that [ __ ] again you
stupid [ __ ] that's it I think so I
wanna get mad I think so because it's
like evolved so much [ __ ] bury her
alive I would literally assuming she
didn't know that he was with someone if
she knew [ __ ] I was in the picture I'd
[ __ ] her up I would chop the clothes off
and I would make sure that she would
never run again because she loved but
she still has a live [ __ ] we got I
don't give a [ __ ] nobody wants to nobody
wants none of that [ __ ] bloody stumps
really guys are disgusting they [ __ ] a
couch I don't give a [ __ ] I know she
running him being act and I'll take that
away from her you're gonna [ __ ] her no
but not really [ __ ] I working her
because you're taking my legs it was a
joke god I said to Jason if she I need
me told this to her before I was like if
you [ __ ] leave me just to let you
know I'm gonna die so have it on your
conscience why would you die huh I will
make it happen
who would I you were dying I would die
if she were to leave if you leave me I'm
dead so have no any conscience i I
genuinely well I've already told her to
like if let's say as of right now right
something crazy happens she there was a
huge car accident she passes away I
guarantee you I probably want to be in
another relationship forever Wow um but
you know me I'm [ __ ] loyal dude
because and the reason why is because I
never got to fall out of love with you
you just left me and I you just taken
from me so I wouldn't beautiful I would
is it I don't know I just I just don't
have that thing and I told her she's
like you would be oz like I don't think
I can because if you're gone like
there's no closing of this chapter yeah
would that girl be okay of me visiting
your grave every year the day that you
died when we were together my god you're
a Korean troll I am a Korean drama
I'm loyalist [ __ ] but and I told her to
like if we had a kid and you passed away
a hundred percent I'm not yeah anybody
you I'll just be single for the rest of
my life and then we'll just have a kids
that's it
you know how much pussy's gonna be
thrown at you know that you just said
that but that's just how I love that
like to know that like you [ __ ] long
for us that much we're gonna be like oh
we want to be with you now I've told her
that too but I said like if she if I
pass away and then she's with somebody
else just know I'm gonna haunt you
forever see I'm gonna haunt you you
could do it yeah but I'm gonna be
watching you guys [ __ ] all the time
just like there's just why the ghost my
god so just to let you know like I just
I don't have that I think they took me
so long to find somebody that I can
really respect appreciate and connect
with to have to go through all that over
again just to find something else that
to be honest with you probably won't be
as good as this person that I had before
[ __ ] is not workable why I think
because um like I know you very well but
you're I don't get to see this side of
you for obvious reasons but like like
yeah to hear you say that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] that's beautiful man yeah
like I'd like the the type of love that
I have from Ariel it's pretty intense
like she may not understand it because
she wants me to be more with the verbal
affirmation and stuff like that which I
think I do give a lot she just wants a
lot more which is hard for me but like
because we've been through so much and I
really love where we're at right now
it's just to have that taken away from
me is something that I just don't want
like I can't do I can't deal with it
because it took so long and I and and
and people have to realize too like if
you like a lot of qualities about me
right now in a relationship it's only
because I was with Muriel yeah so even
the thought of me like cheating on her
means that I have to disregard all the
positive things that she's done for me
Who I am now is because of her so if you
like this stuff out of me is only
because of her yeah she's not there
these qualities are also gone as well so
I am a better person because she brings
that out of me these are like good
beautiful
oh is that poetry yeah that's [ __ ]
beautiful that's where that's the type
of loyalty that I have for her so it's
like if like yeah you know what I when I
was younger and I went on shows him we
were first going out like I would
specifically just go to shows and go
into my hotel room because you know like
we're still fresh and young so if I had
any thoughts fantasies wild yeah and you
know what I throw that you would throws
at you you don't saying far away tell me
some stories man dude there would be
times two and I told these people to
like there was a girl who [ __ ] stole
my I always get two hotel keys she took
one out of my wallet she'd always showed
up in my room and I was like damn [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] in flip-flops and socks hell
you got some low self-esteem yeah that
is a little self-esteem [ __ ] is the
best use me give me girl I'll work with
you yeah you know like [ __ ] like that
but like for me it's just and all that
stuff doesn't matter even like sex too
it's like sex you could really get sex
anywhere if you want yeah it's that
accessible yeah you know maybe not if
you get a [ __ ] hooker it doesn't
matter you can get [ __ ] or dick
whenever you want that's not an in so
maybe not an inside thing yeah so like
all that stuff that I see - it's like
that's the stuff that really just makes
me not care about anything else it's
like oh [ __ ] like I'm a good person and
I had these great relationship qualities
because I learned it from her that's so
cute
stop you're gonna make me cry you [ __ ]
I really AM is beautiful yeah that's
beautiful
cuz imagine to even for all the stuff
that you and Bart went through a lot of
the stuff that you were allowed to find
out about yourself is because you found
somebody who wanted to take the time to
go through your [ __ ] yeah and
because of that you're allowed to evolve
there's a lot of people who goes who
sees flaws and people and they run away
right there's not a lot of people who
want to root and say you know what if
you're gonna go through this I'm gonna
go through it with you and they'll
figure it out yeah I've left a lot of
relationship cuz I'm like I'm not your
mom yeah like I don't want to be here
for this exactly I do that with like
certain friends too sometimes
mmm you know I don't want to be people's
parents and moms so it's like I don't
want to deal with this [ __ ] yeah there
was a there was a moment to wear a
marionette when we first moved in
together I I was having like a bit of an
anxiety attack because I I hate it when
my space is in control that's why can
smoke weed I don't like not being in
control and so I couldn't get the
podcast room right I couldn't get things
unpacked in time because I was
travelling in between things so much so
I was staying up to like 4:00 a.m.
everyday organizing cleaning not
sleeping at all eating still of course
but I wasn't but yeah you didn't look
like you were Millers yeah and all I was
quite nourished and I just wouldn't
sleep and I just [ __ ] snap one day
cuz things weren't fitting in the
podcast room right so I was [ __ ]
cursing up a storm just kind of break
[ __ ] and she just came in she didn't get
mad at me and she was like I'm gonna
take you out we're gonna go out to eat
you're gonna step away from this room
and we're just gonna relax it's like no
I got if she goes no you're not gonna
touch it full man and she just took me
away and I don't I don't know any woman
that I've been with it has ever done
that for me yeah it's hard because we
take it personally said exactly and she
was able to not take it personal sure
and then step away and say I need to
help my fiance rather than tell him he's
being dumb and I was like oh [ __ ] these
are the small moments I'm like
registering I'm like this is this is the
woman that I'm gonna keep for the rest
of my yeah and what no matter what
random [ __ ] that I ever come by or
whatever that [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ]
matter because yeah you will never ever
do that stuff that's the stuff that
she's done for me ever yeah but you
would maybe at times might take it you
might find it funny but she's always my
ride-or-die damn dog yeah that's when
you I think that's a good key to find
like when you really find somebody it's
like oh this person's here for me no
matter what even when I was sick she's
making me food she's making me sue when
you hook up with people they don't do
that [ __ ] for you they're just there
dick and [ __ ] invest and they move on
yeah and that's why I like monogamous
relationships because we get to develop
these relationships that have something
so much more intensity than that first
like first [ __ ] yeah that's intense
that's passion but when you move past
that yeah there's just it's just this
weird thing that you don't know what if
I can tell you experience it yeah and I
mean just even on the topic of sex when
you find that person that you really
connect with on that deep level even the
sex is more intense Oh first like you
don't even have to this is gonna be
[ __ ] extra r-rated but you don't even
have to be thrusting or moving it's like
you can just you could be you can be
just they can be inside you or whatever
you're inside and just that alone you're
just like goddamn is the best [ __ ] ever
yeah there's so much deep connection and
like passion that that you don't need
that porn [ __ ]
yeah like emotional sex - is is always
the best and I've always said - if she
knows - like I've been hooked up with a
lot of women you know I mean like big
surprise yeah what ever did like I've
always said this - like the mountain
when am i enticing was on it's on two
hands that's about it but the only time
that I've really yeah we got a bunch of
lead are you counting this part though
bro not that but we like when I've had
to hooked up with women that I weren't
wasn't really dating it was because I
was going through a [ __ ] dry spell
and I think I just need to [ __ ] somebody
and it's happened like a couple of times
but but it was always the worst sex like
it was just because I just wanted to nut
you know and yeah it got the job done
but after it was like yeah it was cool
Michelle with your clothes on huh then I
started crying a little bit and I shaved
my head you wouldn't eat for days I
wouldn't pretend I would eat for days
but it was always like a weird
experience I started to realize that a
lot of the stuff that that my guy
friends told me like getting [ __ ]
random [ __ ] that they thought it was
very satisfying I wanted to say it's
[ __ ] with them because that's who
they are right they like that [ __ ] but
for me it never felt the same when I was
in a serious relationship and we were
having sex that's when it felt the
[ __ ] best yeah and that's what I kind
of started to chase that's why I like
monogamous relationships because when we
were having fun laughing enjoying each
other and then we would [ __ ] that was
like peak [ __ ] yeah oh this is what
emotional sex feels like [ __ ] a
random person
is here yeah that's how it is for me
anyways it doesn't have to be like that
for you but when you get to connect with
somebody everything just feels so much
better
yeah absolutely absolutely becomes like
this dope dance and you're like damn did
I just do that just is this poor thought
it almost feels like a task to I felt
like when I was if I had sex with
somebody that I didn't really know that
well like it almost felt like I
I always had a commission it was like I
have to make sure that this girl feels
good I think that she comes
because I want to be known as a good sex
partner yeah yeah so I wasn't really
[ __ ] it wasn't for who the [ __ ]
female community like she's gonna go and
talk to the [ __ ] Facebook listen yes
David so you're like wow exactly so it
was such a weird thing and it felt very
robotic it felt like like what was I
really [ __ ] for if you wanted the nut
Brody she's just [ __ ] jacked off and
then moved on it was the whole point of
that [ __ ] there was this whole ordeal
you everybody were seeking the
relationship you were like trying to
convince yourself like because you had
such a dry spot where you're like well
I'm not [ __ ] her because I'm just I
need her [ __ ] yeah as vulgar as that
sounds you're like she's probably funny
she's she's a good girl yeah you can
rationalize it yeah a lot of things cuz
even like somebody who I was with for a
quick instance like I rationalized
giving her a chance because she went out
of her way to ask me out which was
although that's very bold for a woman I
was like she's probably a cool person
even though we were friends at the time
and I renew that we weren't a good match
but I kind of rationalized it right and
then it lasted like two weeks and she
flipped out on me got mad I knew she had
a short temper and I told to get out the
place and then we never talked again Dan
we're friends but we would we didn't
talk like that again his wife great
great so it's like you know when you're
horny you could rationalize anything
dude yeah that's all Bart was cuz uh for
those of you that don't know apart and I
were friends before we got together and
we were friends for like three years
so I remember seeing so he's like this
righteous guy right and like he has the
[ __ ] sharpest straightest moral
compass you ever meet um so for him he'd
never wanted to hook up with girls he
didn't love mm-hmm
there was a swan chick that I saw this
is the world this is the story of where
I saw them having sex in public because
I was my boyfriend at the time mm-hmm
but yeah like he would have this girl
around and he swore up and down that he
loved her but she was like everyone was
like nah bro like just admit it you just
want to [ __ ] her because she's you just
want to [ __ ] her yeah like no I swear I
love her and then after the fact is like
yeah I think I just was trying to
rationalize it like I didn't I didn't
love her she's pretty [ __ ] down what
that's so funny that's the only one
though that's the only one bart has
where he was just like I think he
because he was before me he was single
for like three years
oh sure yeah he's like and he wasn't
sleeping around with chicks or anything
either
like if anything I'm like bro she just
threw herself at you like what the [ __ ]
are you you should it like this is me
being his friend I'm like dude you
should have like he would have girls
sleep in his bed and they didn't do
anything my club are you serious bro
that's so funny
yeah that was not gonna happen with me
if you were sleeping in my bed I'm gonna
write that's not gonna happen with me
either if I'm sleeping in your bed we're
doing something like some anything we're
gonna even if it's just making out for
hours I'm not gonna be like okay good
night and then turn around like mine is
Gina Gina slept in everybody's bed she
was just well she would always come over
some home girl she wouldn't yeah she
would come over to sleep over after she
would get dumped by somebody and I'm
like she's like bawling yeah it's not it
or not I might I just go crash
everyone's little brother for sure yeah
so I was like oh she was she's a little
different you read the room on that one
you know he's like yeah
go [ __ ] fix yourself dude go sleep
she just didn't want to be alone in her
place it's like I yeah I mean I've had
my moments with you moments that sounded
weird
we had a show in San Francisco and then
it was just you and I we were in the
hotel yeah but like that was cool like I
didn't ever feel weird so this is what I
really was such a big [ __ ] you forgive
you I was about to say some [ __ ] she
[ __ ] [ __ ] guy though I forgot the
camera she was she was in her hotel
rooms across from Ryan right and I
didn't realize that she got freaked out
by [ __ ] but I was like alright cool so
I'm very scared I like started like
knocking on her door rattling [ __ ] then
she was freaky I didn't know she was
scared of ghosts I think she cuz she I
[ __ ] her up so mentally because of all
those like weird ghost sounds that I was
making she was like I gotta sleep in
here now oh [ __ ] I was dying laughing
cuz I didn't realize how freaked out she
gets about that [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
terrified I'm really trying to work on
that now but I'm [ __ ] terrified of
that
[ __ ] I'm like traumatized nothing's
happened to me but I'm just very [ __ ]
traumatized I felt a little bad after
because I didn't know how serious it was
a little bad I was like oh it's really
bad even till this day out like
sometimes I just have to sleep with my
phone on yeah I told bar to it's like
you know I didn't know she is freaked
out about that [ __ ] dude I was like
doing like ghost [ __ ] and she got
freaked the [ __ ] out he was cracking up
yeah you're like the few guys that I
would trust to ever do that with of
course I'm doing [ __ ] no no I know but
like I just always like that's going
back to me acting like a man all the
time yeah that's that's why I always
understand that too because even Muriel
knows that too like she sees me with a
lot of like clothes like home girls and
it's because there's no ulterior motive
like I the company of women and men are
different right I like my men company I
also like my women company and the
problem with a lot of guys is that when
they hang out with women they always
have this weird ulterior motive to me
around them and females always feel it
yeah and the girls aren't dumb you know
they could well some girls are but they
are but they still feel it but they deny
it or they rationalizing or they make it
something else I agree we feel it yeah
they feel it you know I mean and so when
a guy doesn't have an old tears like oh
he just wants to hang out it's nice you
know I mean and also to like how I met
her too was through Bart it was there
they were a couple like they're a unit
so there's always Bart and Gio Barton
Gio so that's that's the relationship
that we developed right there's the
other friends way when I got with Mariel
we had a very flirtatious friendship
like they were kind of like cuddle
buddies we're not friends anymore we
can't be friends because that's not how
our relationship started so they would
come over they would like you know they
would sleep hamp no that's different no
well that's if they were if they were
single and they were drives but they
would come over we would hang out or
whatever whatnot you know cuddle buddies
and [ __ ] like that okay a little bit of
game but those those those relationships
had to be cut immediately yes we can't
go from that and just be regular friends
you guys hear that that's a [ __ ]
mature man for you there no I mean
because you're being mature but there's
also guys that are like well she was my
friend no that's not well come on now
that's not friends that's not friends at
all when I when I when I was traveling
there was a girl that week I guess we're
not really friends because we were kind
of fooling around a little bit but
this is what Mary and I were first
started like dating and stuff and we
were going out and then we kind of
solidified it so I went out to Florida
and this girl kind of like wrote
something a little weird that didn't
make me feel comfortable anymore because
once I'm committed I'm committed and
kind of what she wrote was like blah
blah blah it was all fun and games done
let's hang out let's get some drinks or
whatever even though we kind of messed
around a little bit but it wasn't
anything serious but then when I went
back to the hotel she wrote hey I missed
you I was like no no nothing's got weird
because now we were having drinks and
now you wrote I missed you and I write
to her back I was like hey you're kind
of this is where you kind of cross the
line so we can't slide a few if you guys
have been messing around though no cuz I
at this point I told I was in a serious
well I see I can't write I miss you
yeah right because I'm an open book
Muriel can open up my phone she has my
passcode whatever it doesn't matter
god I don't I don't like hiding things
from her so I was like you can't write
stuff like I miss you so if you write
that that means we're not friends yeah
so we have to cut that out let's tie it
yeah so it was just like weird that's
dope and that was kind of hard for me to
cuz she and I just got together so it
was like I don't know what was gonna
happen with Muriel yeah no that's [ __ ]
respectful this [ __ ] yeah it's like
space so that's you know I think it's
really important to like if you guys
really do believe in like platonic
friendships and relationships you have
to be that type of guy yeah cuz I mean
how [ __ ] up is that right like even
though you didn't know if you marry oh
we're gonna last like you already I
committed to her yeah you committed yes
um but like the relationship started off
on the right foot
mm-hmm because let's say it failed or
whatever but now it's like you kind of
feel scummy cuz you just were like well
let me keep people in my pocket yeah
like that's [ __ ] up yeah and you know
if you're in an open relationship those
are like different stories true very
very true the difference that we haven't
mentioned in an open relationship both
parties are very aware that it's an open
relationship exactly so it's not like
you are like I have an open relationship
Muriel is like well it's just we're
monogamous like that's completely
different for sure I've I know somebody
right now and even you know it's like
you know who they are but yeah they you
know it's like the one person's inner
open relation but the other person it's
like that's not an open relationship
that you're just cheating you know
yeah I dunno maybe I dunno yeah it
doesn't really work out like that yeah
so crazy like how much like I've seen
you like grow in the last like three
years
just like emotion not just you it's just
you and Bart yeah and like you guys have
just become a more tight unit Lee that
you guys are a lot more affectionate a
lot more loving yeah just to each other
just to other people as well you know
like when I first came to JK these
[ __ ] didn't hug like they
didn't hug and I hugged everybody and I
didn't know that they didn't hugs I just
giving out hugs [ __ ] all loved
it we were like we were like icicles
slowly thawing out guys I like Bart dude
like I liked when I first met Barton
jealous like I [ __ ] like these guys
yeah the best yeah I was like these guys
are like my type of people they're super
[ __ ] funny easygoing
well this [ __ ] loyalist [ __ ] I gave Bart
and Joe some Joe was a little hard to
get up give hugs yeah I mean I I kind of
had to I kind of forced it upon him a
little bit Bart was way easier once he
was okay with it it was hugs all day
really I felt like he was always a
hugger but coming from my [ __ ] cold
ass yeah well yeah well Joe Joe was not
easy with hugs like it was very whatever
yeah no jokes really good with it yeah I
mean he'll swear to you up and down
though that he's a hugger since high
school I would hold all the girls
besides I'm like whatever bro yeah now I
love hugging bar do bar games like
[ __ ] hugs yeah you squeezes your butt
- yeah yeah like I love hug him because
it feels like very warm and accepting
you feel very small I do I feel like he
could kill me at any point he could just
snap my spine yeah he loves you like I
mean when but you feel the love that he
has for people when he hugs you oh for
sure like yeah that's why I wait like do
you not GOI Merida was like and you was
just like kind of hug and hang on Bart
is like I really like him a lot dude
like I like him he feels like a brother
that I never had you know I mean like I
have a brother now but it's like I was
like bro just different type of
relationships right cuz my brother
relationship was different he feels like
that other missing brother that was
always a part of my family gotcha you
know it means so and I and I always
connected to him you know what it is
your brother respects you your older
brother respects you and he gives you
know he he sees you as an independent
human whereas Bart he
he doesn't respect he bullies you all
the [ __ ] time I like it and you
that's what you grew up watching on TV
the shitty brother that's what Bart is I
know but like because of Bart - I've
like I've done a lot of things that I
thought I couldn't do right so it's like
even like with Mort I'd like I I got
into Muay Thai because apart cuz I saw
him do it not like I did it like 10
years ago well Bart's doing maybe I'll
try it - and they came obsessed with it
and I wanted to level up and match him a
little bit and now we're gonna happen
and now we sparked each other and now we
spar each other and it's fun right I
wanted to give him something where he's
not babying me while we spar it's time
now we could spa reach other like so
it's fun yeah and so much respect for
you oh man I love you we'll never tell
you but he has so much respect for you
he's so proud of you like he's always
talking about how he's [ __ ] proud of
you and he thinks you're so [ __ ]
creative and talented and he thinks
you're like that's my blast my as I'm
always chasing him a little bit that's
the weird thing right it's like I don't
think I have to but I like chasing this
older figure yeah I mean it makes me
feel like I have something to look
forward to and I have something to bring
to the table maybe it's something that
you have but Bart has always been very
like he's always bullied me but he's
very kind and whatever real boy yeah
it's not real boy it always feels fine
and it's always nice I was like I've
always appreciated that relationship so
that's why like even now like you know I
would I don't do JK news but we still
hang out you know I mean like we make
effort to see each other and that's
that's the cool thing that's like I
don't really do that with a lot of
people is like if I see I see yeah yeah
if you guys just like Bart always
reaches out and I try to reach out you
know we go hiking and we see each other
we have breakfast I love seeing tyka
it's important that I develop this
relationship because I want to keep it
for a very long time yeah I love that
that's how you married us dude I know
man I love that I think I think I think
like even though our relationship at
that point was Nick in a weird space
like I love that it happened like that
you know a night and I've even been
thinking about like renewing our vows
you know that be tight because now we're
like at a different phase you know like
I'm a difficult one it would but then I
think just the memories of that and like
uh let me turn into a matter I'm just
having all those people like I'm like
[ __ ] it's not it's not gonna be the same
you know but there's some people we
could I could I could've done out though
without a few people there
that's funny yeah yeah like I don't know
we just we love you and like like you're
the [ __ ] man man you know how it is Doug
Debs so always been loving family
members man that's how I'm gonna do this
is Dave lon how are you feeling
Mel but I'm [ __ ] happy like I I'm
like the happiest I've ever been this is
the most secure with myself that I've
ever been I feel it too um yeah my mind
is clear I'm not constantly like feeling
anxious like is this person gonna accept
me like him do I belong at this table
you know like like I just feel really
good yeah there's there's like these
like small moments that I always like
look back on and I I think I can always
like figure why like our relationship is
so strong even when you're like when
your father passed away like I didn't
really know your dad right but that [ __ ]
was like that she kind of hurt me
because I saw how much you hurt your mom
and I how much it hurt you right
and it was weird cuz I didn't really
know your dad I won't meet your dad
laugh once you know and I she was total
that's huge yeah your dad laughs and he
took it away from you so fast yeah yeah
that's him
he's mine yeah do those huge 100 laughs
I was like admission was so fleeting I
was like I'm not even sure if it was my
joke but I'm I think it was mine yeah I
knew it was so cool and then when your
father passed away it was huge and just
like I remember just like watching your
mom cry that she [ __ ] hurt me dude
and she was just you know asking me
she's like be there for geo like be
there for her I was like oh yeah but
just like small moments like that just
like I've see I've been like through so
many parts of your like stages of your
life your relationship from you having
kids it's like you're such an integrated
part of my life now is like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] ain't leaving I know I can't even
cut you out even if I wanted to know
some of my best memories is with you
Bart and Joe in the last 10 years it's
times crazy like hope like hold the
Hawaii trips that we went on even when
we all got those brand-new cars together
right like he got his Porsche Joe got
the Jag and I got the Tesla like yeah
[ __ ] we're all like coming up together
and then we started businesses together
it's like [ __ ] man like this is this is
like you kind of like living the dream
that you've always wanted when you were
younger in you is actually happening
you're working with your friends
making good money your family's becoming
better your friends are becoming better
this is a good life and it allows me to
reflect on these things and I'm very
very happy about it
how does it make you feel people are
ungrateful it [ __ ] makes me mad I
like reflecting on these things and I
think that keeps always keeps me in a
very positive headspace and like I've
said you grow so much - yeah you're like
one of my favorite people do you hear
that [ __ ] you hear that that's
all I was I was just working this guy
even though our shoes - I was like
really trying to make eye contact I just
want to say I did it
I want to thank God right now even
though she's dressed like a 1990s
Brooklyn rapper now I know one of my
favorite favorite [ __ ] people did you
see so she's so like easy to be around I
genuinely love being around her I love
giving her hugs I love giving her kids
it feels like I've because I always
wanted an older sister and so like to
you that's what you always feel like to
me so that's why I always like giving
her hugs I like being around her is
because it feels so easy and it's hard
like that with like certain freshness
sometimes when you have friends now you
always feel like you have to be on yeah
right with you I never have to be on so
it's like oh you always joke around [ __ ]
around and then it's just nice it's nice
years sink into your water and you've
always been like that though right so
that's why I have always been drawn
towards you because I always felt you
were so [ __ ] warm like you were
always warm yeah you made me feel safe
in my night when I was just in my own
head about just who I was I just always
felt really comfortable with you because
you just made me feel like no matter
what phase in my life I was in or the
dump [ __ ] that I that I thought I said
or that I actually did say um I just
never felt judgment from you I never
felt any negativity I just felt like you
genuinely understood me and you saw the
best in me
so I was like thank you yeah I'm always
on your side - I'm always on your guys's
side man like even like it doesn't
really matter I think that's like the
the loyalty thing that a lot of people
forget about like loyalty doesn't mean
that you just had that person's back no
matter what
I think loyalty means that you're just
willing to stick around with that person
even though when they're flawed yeah
dude that's the heart means like it
really is just like there cuz it's easy
to love someone at their best
yeah for sure and they'll [ __ ] up they
might even [ __ ] up some stuff in the
friendship and the relationship
you should be able to move past that and
move on yeah and I think like with you
guys I haven't had any real trouble with
you guys ever I've never ever looked at
you a Bart Joe or anything but like I
hate you or I you pissed me I know we've
like been in a lot of situations like
we've traveled together believe me we've
worked together yeah I don't think I've
ever been angry at any of you guys which
is you annoy me sometimes I'm on owing
guy though yeah well but that's about it
I've never like really been mad I've
never been mad at you guys I'm like huh
that's so interesting
like I've and I don't know around you
got a lot yeah yeah a lot a lot yeah so
I was like wonder what that is
especially traveling to that's when you
really get to see people's color working
I think also cuz we're very like go with
the flow though we're never like cement
when we travel this has to happen we
have to do this we're just like it
didn't happen let's move on we'll figure
it out so it's always just very nice to
have that yeah because when people try
to take control of situations all the
time is when I get stressed out relaxed
provocation it's not a big deal man
usually you brain jackass shoutouts my
uncle dude yeah I love you once
well guys that wraps in this episode the
genius two hours goddamned walk I still
got more in me know we could talk for
days man the next one Bart's gonna come
on and yeah that is gonna be you and
head together yeah I'm trying to spread
this [ __ ] out yes genius brain needs
great guests I can't wait till I can't
wait till me and barter together and
talk so much [ __ ] to you oh you wish I'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] guns blazing dude come
you're gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] gun
complaining guys I gotta come
complaining no but I want to bring you
two together because I want to hear
about the inception of your guys
relationship from two different
perspectives and it's always funny when
couples talk about a second so different
I can't wait to [ __ ] do it let's do
it I'm ready I'm ready
well guys you guys can catch the genius
brain podcast on all audio platforms
give us that five stars deal where can
they find you laughs if they don't
already know uh just Google me I'm just
kidding I'm on Instagram geo underscore
let's run it on YouTube Barton geo
barbell brigade I'm all over the place
baby JK a news check it out I'm there
barbar gay man they got some dope bad
[ __ ] dude I always be wearing it all the
time almost makes me feel like I
stronger when I wear it
yeah you do yep I ten horsepower baby
see y'all next time peace I